SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER-
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING BASE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE. REMOTELY
HOWEVER TODAY WE WILL NOT HAVE
ANY MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS. THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO MAKE RECOGNIZE
IT USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TEAM TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU'D LIKE TO
ANYA. POLICE SELECTOR ME BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE
WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC INTO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER WITH ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL DUTY DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPATE NUMBER IS.
844-291-4185 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN FOUR NINE SEVEN
NINE. EIGHT SEVEN. COULD
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TELECOM. TO
MY- PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
ANDORRA COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID COULD STICK FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET YOUR DEVICE THAT YOU
WERE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING HIS TESTIMONY.
OVER THE PHONE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS. AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
MANNER AS PERSIMMON IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
WAIT TIMES WE ASK FOR YOUR-
PATIENCE. OKAY IN TODAY'S
HEARING WILL BE PREVIEWING
SPRING FINANCE PROPOSALS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF.
REHABILITATION DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING WELL WE WOULD BE
DISCUSSING. OTHER BUDGET
PROPOSALS THAT THE SENATE IS
ALSO CONSIDERING FOR INCLUSION
IN THE BUDGET- AND ONE. ISSUE
THAT WE WERE GOING TO COVER
THAT WE ARE GOING TO WAIT UNTIL
LATER. IS- UP ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
THE HAVE TO DO WITH THE DEAF
AND DISABLED. THAT WILL BE.
HEARD AT A LATER DATE. I WILL
NOTE THAT ALL ITEMS IN THE
AGENDA WILL BE UP FOR
DISCUSSION BUT THE SUB
COMMITTEE. WILL NOT BE VOTING
ON ANY ITEMS TODAY WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END. OF
THE HEARING AFTER ALL THE ITEMS
HAVE BEEN HEARD- OUR FIRST-
THE- AGENDA ITEM THEN- I AND IS
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT. BUT NOW IT IS THE
ISSUE NUMBER ONE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION-
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE ISSUE THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HEAR IS
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES IS UNDER
THE ISSUE OF DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION BUT WE WILL BE
HEARING ISSUE NUMBER ONE
EXTENSION OF REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY FOR THE DEATH AND
DISABLED TOILET COMMISSION CAN.
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROGRAM.
OKAY. WELCOME OUR PRESENTERS.
GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN'T. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE- DIRECTOR JONES AB
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION I HAVE WITH ME
ALSO IF CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
ENDING THE DRUG OF WHO WAS
JOINING ME ON TODAY'S. MEETING
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME AND
PRESENT TWO YEARS AGO AND TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE- HERE GENDER DOES
A GOOD JOB OF DESCRIBING THE
ISSUE FOR YOU AS WELL JUST GET
EMPHASIZE A COUPLE OF KEY
POINTS ONE IS- THE REQUEST FOR
THE TWO. POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ALREADY AND THEN THE
SWEEPING POINT TWO POSITIONS AS
A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT TO ALLOW
IS THE AUTHORITY TO CONTINUE TO
ROLL OUT THE VOICE OPTIONS
PROGRAM WHICH REALLY PROVIDES
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH SIGNIFICANT. SPEECH
DISABILITIES. TO PHAM DANA TO.
AND IT'LL IN NAPLES INDIVIDUALS
TO RACINE FREE. GENERATING
DEVICE THAT THEN THEN IN USE
TO- VOICE AND GIVE VOICE TO
THEIR OWN- COMMUNICATION OUT OF
THEIR OWN ISSUES SO I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF QUICK-
IMPACTS. FROM WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED THIS FAR IN THE ROLLOUT
OF THE PROGRAM. FIRST OF ALL WE
ARE SERVING INDIVIDUALS ON
BETWEEN EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND
SEVEN YEARS OLD- ONE OF THE
TESTIMONY THAT WE RECEIVED- IS
FROM A PARENT OF A FIFTEEN YEAR
OLD. DATA WAS SO APPRECIATIVE
THAT HER SON WAS NOW ABLE TO
ARTICULATE THROUGH HIS OWN
VOICE HIS WISHES AND THE
ABILITY- TO BETTER COMMUNICATE
WITH HER AND WITH- HIS PEERS
OUT. LIKE WISE- AN INDIVIDUAL
UNDER THE AGE OF TWELVE- WAS
I'M NOW ABLE TO ALSO
EFFECTIVELY OF MORE EFFECTIVELY
COMMUNICATE. WITH HIS PARENTS
AND SO A MOM WAS EXTREMELY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE OPPORTUNITY
VOWED TO THIS PROGRAM PROVIDED
TO- HER SON AS WELL SO I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO CHIEF DEPUTY
REMOVED. RIGHT TO ADD A LITTLE
BIT MORE DETAIL. GOOD MORNING
AND- THANK YOU FOR HEARING US
THIS MORNING- THERE AS- DOCTOR
EXAM HERE MENTION THIS IS A AND
A WONDERFUL PROGRAM- THAT THAT
ALLOWS- PEOPLE WITH- SPEECH
DISABILITIES TO EFFECTIVELY
COMMUNICATE AND THAT'S IT. A
PILOT PROGRAM AS YOU KNOW-
THERE WERE SOME INITIAL DELAYS
IN ROLLING OUT THE PROGRAM-
LAST LAST YEAR- WE REQUESTED-
AN EXTENSION OF THE
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY AGAIN-
AND WE WERE SCHEDULED TO. START
THE PILOT ON- MARCH FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY- AND WE ALL KNOW-
WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR WITH CO
ED- NOT TO MENTION WILDFIRES
AND PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFFS- IN SO THERE WAS SOME
DELAY LAST YEAR AS WELL- WHICH
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE REQUESTING
AN EXTENSION OF THE
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY. I AM
HAPPY TO REPORT THAT- WE WERE
ABLE TO ROLL OUT THE PILOT-
WITH A START DATE OF JULY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY- THAT DELAY
WAS DUE TO. REALLY SHIFTING TO.
PROVIDE THE SIR. REMOTELY
DEMONSTRATING- SERVICES
REMOTELY- AND THE LIKE- WE
HAVE- WE HAVE SUB CONTRACTED
WITH- TWELVE PROVIDERS
CURRENTLY IN TWENTY ONE
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
OUR GOAL. IN HAS BEEN TO SERVE
FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE IN THE
PILOT- WE'VE ON IN IN THE SHORT
PERIOD OF JULY FIRST UNTIL. NOW
WE HAVE SERVED A HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE INDIVIDUALS- WITH THE
TARGET OF TWO HUNDRED BY THE
END OF. THIS FISCAL YEAR AND
ANOTHER THREE HUNDRED. NEXT
FISCAL YEAR SO- SO WHERE WHERE
UNDER WAY DESPITE DESPITE THE
DELAYS AND- KRISHI EIGHT ATKINS
OF EXTENSION OF THE
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING ON
THIS. I LEARNED EARLIER FINANCE
DONE NOTHING TO ACT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RESPECT. HELLO HEY
HEY GOOD MORNING- MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN AND SENATORS- WE
HAVE REVIEWED THIS PROPOSAL WE
THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO EXTEND
ITS ALREADY TO FINISH THE PILOT
WHICH WAS AUTHORIZED BY BUDGET
LEGISLATION BACK IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- ES MIS MARKED MOVE
DRAKE- NOTED THIS IS THE SECOND
EXTENSION- REQUESTED FOR THIS
PILOT PROGRAM SO WE WOULD NOTE
THAT IT IS- IT'S RATHER
UNFORTUNATE THAT. THE POTENTIAL
PILOT PARTICIPANTS WERE NOT
ABLE TO ACCESS THE SPEECH
GENERATING DEVICES DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHICH- YOU KNOW MIGHT
HAVE BEEN A VALUABLE SERVICE
STRING AT A CRITICAL TIME.
HOWEVER WE DO RECOGNISE THE-
THE COP THE CONTRACTED AS
SERVICES- OFTEN THROUGH THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS- WE
DO RECOGNIZE WHY STAFF HAD TO
SORT OF SCALE BACK SERVICES
DURING DURING THIS TIME DUE TO
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YES THE CERTAINLY I
THINK WE'VE ALL SEEN THE IT THE
IMPACT OF COVERT ON ON AND THE
USE OF TECHNOLOGY- AND
ESPECIALLY IN OUR- ARE A
POPULATION WHO- OF RT RT ED
HAVING DIFFICULTIES WITH
COMMUNICATION SO. SEEMS LIKE IT
MAKES SENSE AND WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT. BUT THE
PANDEMIC PREVENTED DEALT A LOT
OF THINGS FROM GOING FORWARD
SO- WE'LL BE WE'LL BE EXCITED
TO HEAR. WHAT MY GOOD THINGS
COMES FROM THE START TO PASS
ANYTHING ON THIS ISSUE. GREAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY EVERYONE SEEMS TO THINK
THIS MAKES A LOT OF SENSE GET A
GREAT VIEW IN PRODUCTIVE PAN
OKAY- SO LET US MOVE ON TO THE
PART THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES TO HAVE THE
DIRECTOR HERE. THE MORNING
DAVID GILBERT DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES MONEY. MONEY GOOD
MORNING OKAY ISSUE NUMBER ONE
CHILD SUPPORT. AGENCY WELL. THE
SPRING B. C. P. ADDRESS WHAT
WAS OCCURRING IN JANUARY WE HAD
PUT TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO
SUPPLEMENT LOCAL TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO BRING PARITY ACROSS
THE COUNTIES WERE FURTHER
EXPANDING IT BY AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A TOTAL OF FIFTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
REALLY GETS BACK ON TRACK TO
THE EFFORTS WE WERE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH THE LEGISLATURE
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC OF THREE
YEARS OF FINDING TO GET UP TO.
A LEVEL FUNDING FOR THE LOCAL
CHANNELS FOR AGENCIES THIS IS
THE FIRST STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION AND JUST IDENTIFIES
HOW THAT FIFTY SIX MILLION WILL
BE SPREAD OUT ACROSS THE
UNDERFUNDED COUNTIES OF WHICH
THERE ARE A FEW MORE THAN OUR
PREVIOUS CONVERSATION BECAUSE
OF RISING COSTS AND THE
REDUCTION OF THE LOCAL TRUCKS
REYES YOU TEND TO TAKE DURING.
THE AND- OKAY. THE PART OF
FINANCE. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT. THANK YOU. BELIAU
THANK YOU PROCEED WITH THAT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE AND
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CONTEXT
AS THE STATE WAS GRAPPLING WITH
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET CONSTRAINTS-
IN LIGHT OF COPING NINETEEN
LAST YEAR HE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET WITH A NUMBER
FUNDING REDUCTIONS INCLUDING- I
NINETEEN MILLION GENERAL FUND-
REDUCTION TO LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES HOWEVER GIVEN
THAT- BUDGET CONDITIONS ARE
BETTER THAN EXPECTED ANDTHIS
TIME AROUND THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET DID PROPOSED TO
RESTORE A PORTION. OF AND THE
FUNDING REDUCTION.
I'M NOW
COUPLED WITH THE SPRING FIVE.
HE I MEAN WHETHER THE
METHODOLOGY FULLY MAXIMIZES
PROGRAM EFFICIENCIES AND BEST
PRACTICES- WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT PROPOSING
ANY FUNDING INCREASES BEYOND
THE RESTORATION AT THIS TIME
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER ASKING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ADDRESS THESE
AND ANY OTHER ISSUES. WITH THE
FUNDING METHODOLOGY PRIOR TO
MAKING ANY ADDITIONAL FUTURE
FUNDING REQUESTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- YEAH AND
MY COUNTY IS ON HERE AND I HAVE
CERTAINLY HEARD A LOT ABOUT-
THIS METHODOLOGY AND- AND THE
IMPACT WHEN COUNTIES AREN'T
FUNDED. PROPERLY SO I AM GLAD
TO SEE WE'RE WORKING ON THIS
AND I HOPE WE AT MOVE EVEN
FURTHER IN THIS SPACE AS WE
CARE FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES. DEPEND THANK YOU AND
I APPRECIATE THE L. AS REMARKS
AND I JUST I DO WANT TO THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR NOW. BE
ABLE TO FULLY FUND- SAID THAT
HE THAT MY REMARKS BACK WHEN-
THE CUTS ARE PROPOSED
RECOGNIZING THE DIFFERENT
FINANCIAL SITUATION WHERE AN-
AD MAKE NOTE THAT THE
INVESTMENTS IN- CHILD SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY. BRING
IN MORE RESOURCES TO FAMILIES
SO. I KNOW THAT WHEN WE WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH
COUNTIES AND DEVELOPING THIS
FUNNY METHODOLOGY WHICH NOW
FORTUNATE BE FULLY FUNDED. AT
THE PURPOSE WAS ACTUALLY TO
MAXIMIZE ITS ACTUALLY INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF SUPPORT WE'RE
PROVIDING FAMILIES AND- AND SO
THIS IS VERY GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO DO SO AND TO
CORRECT- SERVE HISTORICAL.
INEQUITIES AND- IN IN TERMS OF-
COUNTY SUPPORT FOR. THE CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH CREATE
THIS MOVING FORWARD AND- ALSO I
WOULD MAKE NOTE ARE ISSUE
NUMBER TWO WILL BE ALSO TRYING
TO ADDRESS THIS VERY ISSUES I'M
TRYING TO MAXIMIZE- THE FUNDING.
FOR AGAIN FAMILIES AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY- OKAY
THEN LET'S MOVE ON TO THAT
NEXT- COMPONENT AND- AND YES
AND WE ARE GLAD TO SEE. THIS
COMING FORWARD AND SO WE'RE TO
ASK THE L. A. O. TWO PERCENT.
ON THE US SOME SENATE BUDGET
OPTIONS TO REDUCE THE STATE IN
FOR IT AND- PUT IT DEBT ON LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS ELIA. AND WE
WERE ASKED TO READ THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS BUDGET PROPOSALS I'M
OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA AND OUR
REMARKS WILL LARGELY BE LIMITED
TO WHAT IS WRITTEN IN THE
AGENDA- ALSO GIVEN THAT THE
PROPOSAL'S ARE RELATIVELY NEW
TO US WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
ANSWER. ALL QUESTIONS BUT WE'LL
BE HAPPY TO GET BACK TO STAFF
AND MEMBERS AS NEEDED. I'M SO
IN THE CASE OF THE CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM- SENATE BUDGET
PROPOSAL IN THE AGENDA THE
SENATE IS CONSIDERING A
PROPOSAL TO REDUCE AND OUR
EXPANSION UNCOLLECTIBLE CHILD
SUPPORT DEBT. OWED TO THE
GOVERNMENT. INCLUDING A TWENTY
TWENTY GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO CEASE
ENFORCEMENT OF A REAR ENGINE IS
DUE TO THE STATE. WHEN THE
PARENTS SOLE INCOME. SOURCE OF
INCOME IS FROM SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME OR STATE
SUPPLEMENTARY PAYMENT BENEFITS
ALSO KNOWN AS ISIS ISIS P. CASH
ASSISTANCE FOR AGE BLIND AND
DISABLED LEGAL IMMIGRANTS
BENEFITS ALSO KNOWN AS CAPPY. A
COMBINATION OF EXERCISES P. AND
SOCIAL SECURITY DISABILITY
INSURANCE BENEFITS OR VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION DISABILITY
BENEFITS. NOTE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD NOT ELIMINATE
ANY DAY AT ANY DEBT OWED TO
FAMILIES ONLY DEBT OWED TO
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES. IN
ADDITION TO WHAT IS INCLUDED IN
THE AGENDA WE WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO NOTE THAT THE MENTIONED
TWENTY TWENTY GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
CEASE ENFORCEMENT.
UNCOLLECTIBLE GOVERNMENT DEBT
OWED DEBT. UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH I JUST
MENTIONED I'M WAS ULTIMATELY
WITHDRAWN BY THE ADMINISTRATION
LAST YEAR AS A RESULTS TO THE
BUDGET UNCERTAINTIES. OF COPING
NINETEEN AT THE TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THIS IS A
THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE THAT THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS BEEN WORKING
ON FOR AWHILE AND I KNOW DOCTOR
PAN HAS BEEN I HAD A LOT OF
INTEREST IN THIS AS WELL- THIS
IDEA OF- AND AGAIN I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT PORTANTINO CLEAR THAT
THE- AS WE- IS THE SENATE'S
PLAN TO BUILD BACK BOLDLY AND
SIMPLY TRY TO. OF MAXIMIZE THE
RESOURCES FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND ANNA AND MAKE
SURE SAFETY NET IS STRONG AND
THAT WE'RE NOT INTENDING FOR
MONEY OWED TO FAMILIES TO GO
AWAY BUT JUST THE MONEY- TO THE
STATE. IN IN SOME WOULD SAY-
THAT THESE THESE LOST OUR FROM-
THAT POVERTY LAWS WE WANT TO
TRY TOPUNISH PEOPLE AND SO THE
DEBT THAT IS COLLECTED FROM
FAMILIES. WORKING PARENTS
OFTENTIMES ARE NEVER ALLOWS
THEM TO GET AHEAD- SO TO IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO HAVE PEOPLE
BE ABLE TO GET MORE TO THEIR
FAMILIES AND NOT AS MUCH TO
STATE PASSAGE THAT. IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND I KNOW
THAT'S- CAN CREATE A WHOLE FOR
THE STATE BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S- THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME MONEY RIGHT NOW
SO WHY DON'T WE USE IT TO BE
ABLE TO. CARE FOR FAMILIES AND
NOT BE WORRIED ABOUT- INTEREST
HAS ACCRUED ON ON PAST THINGS.
DR WE ALSO HAVE A PANELIST HERE
AND- TO HELDER FROM DIVERT NOVA
FINANCIAL JUSTICE PROJECT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO HEAR FROM HER FIRST
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS OR
SOMETHING YOU'D LIKE TO SAY
ABOUT OUR PLAN BEFORE WE GO
FORWARD. OKAY A SORE PANELISTS
NOW WILL BE- WILL BE ON. IN
STROOP STROKE HELP ME IN. THE
STUHLDREHER CLOSE TOOL DREYER
OKAY. THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO
SAY I'M IN A SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL IT'S GOOD FOR FAMILIES
AND IT'S GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA
FOR CALIFORNIA REQUIRING
PARENTS WITH VERY LITTLE
INCOMES TO PAY THE GOVERNMENT
FOR THE COST OF SAFETY NET
SERVICES HAS DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES FOR FATHERS FOR
MOTHERS AND FOR CHILDREN IN
THESE IMPACTS FALL HARDEST ON
LOW INCOME BLACK AND BROWN
FAMILIES ACROSS OUR STATE IT'S
A PRACTICE WHICH DOES FAR MORE
HARM THAN GOOD. THE PUNITIVE
PENALTIES THAT SAID AND WHEN
PARENTS CANNOT PAY THIS DEBT
THAT GROWS AT ASTRONOMICAL
RATES FROM A 10% INTEREST RATE
SUCH AS SUSPENDING THEIR
DRIVER'S LICENSE KNOCKING DOWN
THEIR CREDIT SCORE MAKE IT VERY
HARD- FOR PARENTS TO WORK AND
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES AND THIS
PRACTICE DIRECTLY TAKES MONEY
AWAY FROM CHILDREN IN POVERTY
THE PEOPLE WHO NEED US THE MOST
A FEW YEARS AGO TO ADDRESS
THESE PROBLEMS AND SAN
FRANCISCO WE COLLABORATED WITH
PHILANTHROPIC PROGRAM-
FOUNDATIONS THE STATE AND LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM. AND WE
USE THE COOP PROGRAM TO PAY OFF
THE GOVERNMENT JET OF THIRTY
TWO PARENTS WE THOUGHT IF WE
PAID OFF THIS GOVERNMENT DEBT
THAT THE NON CUSTODIAL PARENTS
IN THE STUDY WOULD MAKE LARGER
AND MORE CONSISTENT PAYMENTS
SINCE THEY KNEW THEIR PAYMENTS
WERE GOING WHERE THEY SHOULD TO
THEIR CHILDREN AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS ACCORDING
TO A STUDY BY THE URBAN
INSTITUTE. THEY WERE FATHERS
LIKE A MAN NAMED JOE WHO
PARTICIPATED JOE WAS STRUGGLING
TO PAY THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
GOVERNMENT OWED CHILD SUPPORT
THAT HE WAS LIVING IN HIS VAN
HIS DRIVER'S LICENSE HAD BEEN
SUSPENDED BECAUSE HE COULDN'T
PAY THIS GOVERNMENT THAT AND IT
WAS HARD FOR HIM O HANG ON TO
HIS JOB AS A SOCIAL SECURITY
GUARD FROM HIS CREDIT WAS SHOT
SO HE COULDN'T REALLY GET INTO
N APARTMENT- AFTER THE
GOVERNMENT. DEBT WAS PAID OFF
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM I'M JOE
GOT DRIVER'S BACK AND HE WENT
TO FOR. HE WAS TO GO INTO AN
APARTMENT HE TO ME ABOUT YOUR
TO HE WAS MORE TIME WITH HIS
KIDS BECAUSE YOU COULD AFFORD
TO DO THINGS WITH THEM. LIKE
TAKE THEM TO GET ICE CREAM OR
GO TO THE MOVIES HE WAS ALSO
SPENDING MORE TIME WITH THE
CHILDREN'S MOTHER PREVIOUSLY HE
WAS JUST DROPPING HIS KIDS OFF
AND THEN TAKING OFF IN HIS CAR.
NOW THEY WOULD CHECK OUT OF
THAT AND THEIR RELATIONSHIP
IMPROVED AND EVERYTHING HE WAS
PAYING WENT TO HIS CHILDREN AND
TO HER AND NOT TO THE
GOVERNMENT. THE STUDY BY THE
URBAN INSTITUTE FOUND THAT WHEN
WE GOT RID OF THIS GOVERNMENT
THAT PARENTS MADE LARGER AND
MORE CONSISTENT PAYMENTS HOW DO
YOU SPELL YOUR STUDENT
REQUIREMENTS. THEIR CREDIT
SCORES WENT UP AND THEY HAD
MORE STABLE HOUSING AND IMPROVE
THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR
PARENTS AND CPARENTS. SO I
SUPPORT ANY EFFORT TO REALLY
LIFT THE BURDEN OF THIS
GOVERNMENT YEAH. FAMILIES
SIMPLY CANNOT IT. I THINK THE-
TO AUTOMATICALLY LIMIT THIS
GOVERNMENT- DEBT. FOR FOLKS WHO
ARE JUST GETTING BY ON SOCIAL
SECURITY OR SSI IS SO IMPORTANT
I RECENTLY SPOKE TO A
GRANDFATHER. FREDDIE PERSONS
WHO LIVES IN THE BAYVIEW AND
SAN FRANCISCO. HE'S GOT SPOTTED
ON A NINE HUNDRED DOLLAR SOCIAL
SECURITY CHECK AND UNTIL
RECENTLY WE WERE GARNISHING AS
A STATE THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
OF HIS CHECK. THAT WENT TO THE
GOVERNMENT IT DIDN'T GO TO HIS
KIDS IT DIDN'T GO TO HIS FAMILY
AND IT MADE IT VERY HARD FOR MR
PERSONS TO GET BY. SO WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY AND AN
OBLIGATION TO REALLY HELP.
FOLKS LIKE MRPERSONS AND LIKE
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES ACROSS
THE STATE WHO ARE STRUGGLING
UNDER THE BURDEN OF THIS STAT.
THIS AUTOMATIC SOLUTION TO LIST
THIS STAT BOB PEOPLE GETTING BY
THESE MEANS TESTED BENEFITS. IS
THE FIRST STEP BUT WE NEED TO
GO MUCH FURTHER AS A STATE AND
ELIMINATE THIS GOVERNMENT- DEBT
ENTIRELY. THAT'S WHAT'S BEST
FOR FAMILIES IN POVERTY AND
THAT'S WHAT'S BEST. FOR
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY. I THINK A YEAH
I DID THINK WHEN THE WHEN THEY
WANT ONE ARE SENATE CAME UP
WITH A PLAN BILL BACK BOLDLY
THIS IS A DRASTIC OF THINGS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW DO
WE- WHAT KIND OF CONCRETE
THINGS CAN WE DO TO RELEASE THE
BURDEN. ON OUR MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES THAT CAN. NO THANK YOU
THANK YOU CARE EGGMAN- YEAH IT.
FIRST OF ALL CERTAINLY S.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
YOU KNOW WE SHOULD MAKE
EVIDENCE BASED POLICY AND- WHEN
WE LOOK AT THIS. WE ALSO THINK.
EVEN FOR OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE
SO EVEN FROM A STRICTLY
FINANCIAL STANDPOINT- WHEN WE
DE MOTIVATE PEOPLE FROM
ESSENTIALLY BE ABLE TO PAY
BECAUSE THEY REALIZED THAT THE
MONEY THEY'RE PUTTING INTO
SPAIN GARNISH OR PUTTING THE
END IS NOT ACTUALLY SUPPORTING
THEIR- THEIR- THEIR- THEIR
CHILDREN- BUT INSTEAD IS BEING.
TAKEN OUT BY THE GOVERNMENT. IN
THE END NOT ONLY THAT MONEY NOT
GETTING TO THE CHILDREN IT
DIDN'T. BUT WE END UP PAYING
FOR IT ANYWAY- I MEAN THROUGH
OUR OTHER PROGRAMS. AND SO- IT
INSTEAD WHAT WE JUST DO IS WE-
WE HAVE A CIRCULAR THING GOING
ON WITH HER. OKAY FINE WE TAKE
MONEY WE STICK IT IN SOME
ACCOUNT BUT THEN WE'RE SPENDING
OTHER STATE MONEY- AND ALSO
LOCAL MONIES TO HELP PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO THE FAMILIES BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT. ABLE TO GET
BECAUSE THE MONEY IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO THEM IT'S GOING TO THE
STATE. AND I THINK THE- SO WE
REALLY SHOULD LOOK WHEN WE LOOK
AT SOME OF THESE POLICIES
REALLY ABOUT- WHAT THE NET
EFFECT REALLY IS ON THE STATE
SO FOR DOES FOR PEOPLE WHO MAY
BE LISTENING AND SAYING WELL
GEE YOU KNOW WHAT. ISN'T THIS
GOING TO COST THE STATE MONEY.
AND AGAIN SOMEONE CAN DO THE
COUNTING ON THIS I WOULD ARGUE
THAT IT WILL COST THE STATE A
LOT LESS MONEY THAN IT MAY SEEM
LIKE ON. THE FRONT BECAUSE IN
THE END WE ARE PAYING. OUT FOR
THIS AS WELL SO EVEN THOUGH WE
DON'T WORK OUR NATION AND
AGAIN- THE PEOPLE ARE PAYING
THESE DEBTS- CERTAINLY WELL
IT'S TO BE BLIND YOU KNOW IF
YOU KNEW THAT THE MONEY THAT
YOU'RE PAYING WASN'T ACTUALLY
GOING TO HELP SUPPORT YOUR
CHILDREN INSTEAD WAS JUST GOING
INTO A- YOU KNOW GOVERNMENT
PARDEE PILIS MOTIVATED TO WORK
THAT EXTRA. A LITTLE HARDER-
THINGS AND OF COURSE I
APPRECIATE THE PAST- THIS-
STILL DREYER TALK TALKING ALSO
ABOUT- HOW THIS DEBT ALSO- YOU
DON'T TAX. THE PERSON'S LIFE IN
A WAY THAT MAKES IT LESS LIKELY
TO ABLE TO INTERACT WITH THE
CHILDREN LESS ABLE TO GET. YOU
KNOW WORK- TO ACTUALLY HURDLE
LIVING WOULD HAVE HELP THEM.
ALSO PAY FOR CHAO SUPPORT SO- I.
THAT AS WE HAVING THIS. OF THIS
THIS NOT BE FRAMED- AS A- WELL
LOOK YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO SPEND X. AMOUNT OF
STATE DOLLARS FOR- LET YOU
KNOW. FOR WAVING THE DATA WE'RE
GOING TO COLLECT LESS STATE
DOLLARS FOR WAITING THIS THAT
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE TRUE
COST. OF THIS POLICY. EVEN FROM
A STRICTLY FINANCIAL POINT OF
VIEW I THINK THAT WE STILL WIN
IN THE END BY ELIMINATING THE
STAT. I WOULD CERTAINLY ARGUE
THAT- FINANCIAL PLUS THE OTHER
OF THE OTHER- IMPACT IT HAS ON
FAMILIES THAT WE DEFINITELY I
BELIEVE WOULD COME OUT AHEAD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND WE THANK YOU THAT. MS IN
CHURCH ROAD RARE FOR HERE A FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY AND- AND
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE YOU'VE
DONE OVER YOUR LIFETIME BUT
MOST RECENTLY IN INSISTS IN SAN
FRANCISCO. OKAY NOW WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND THE
FIRST ISSUE HERE. IF I AM
CORRECT THIS TIME IS THE ONE WE
ARE NOT GOING TO HEAR THIS TIME
BUT WE'LL HEAR IT AT A LATER
DATE SO NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO- HAVING TO DO
WITH THE FORENSIC. DIVERSION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- DOCTOR
PAT IS NANCY BARGE WHEN THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES- AND I'M
JOINED TODAY WITH- MY
COLLEAGUES BRIAN WINFIELD CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. AND CARLA KATZ
MADE AT THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
CARL IS GOING TO PRESENT AN
ISSUE TO- WERE AVAILABLE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS UPON HER
PRESENTATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND GOOD MORNING DISCUSSING
A- THE MORNING- EARLY BECAUSE
HE OTHER DEPARTMENT A LITTLE
SERVICES. THIS ISSUE OF
REQUESTS TWO POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS- IN ADDITION TO
THE CHILEAN ASSEMBLY TWENTY
TWENTY PROJECT. THIS WOULD
ASSEMBLY EXPECT THIS WOULD
SUPPORT THE EXPANDED FORENSIC
DIVERSION PROGRAM WHICH
INCLUDES NONVIOLENT FELONIES-
SO MANY. RESOURCE TO SUPPORT
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF-
COORDINATEDSTATEWIDE EFFORT SO
IT'S NOT A POSITION AT EVERY
REGIONAL CENTER- AS WELL AS AN
ATTORNEY FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
AYE INTO FORENSIC PSYCHOLOGISTS
TO HELP WITH THE RECORD NATION
AT THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
AND BEING COORDINATED EFFORT
SUPPORTS THE VIEW LOOKING FOR
THE APPROPRIATE PLACEMENTS IN
SERVICES TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
AS THEY- GO THROUGH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. HAPPY
TO ANSWERING. CAN YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT ABOUT
WHAT KIND OF SERVICES WILL BE
PROVIDING. SURE THE ESTIMATED
CONTRACT WAS BASED ON SIMILAR
SERVICES AND NEEDS MAY AND
INCLUDE SOCIALIZATION TRAINING.
TRAINING AND ADDITIONAL SKILLED
OR NOT- I WILL DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES IF THERE'S A LITTLE
MORE INFORMATION. YEAH HI GOOD
MORNING AT THE PARCHMENT AGAIN
I'M HAPPY TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CONTACT- REGARDING THE
POSITIONS- WORK WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING ABLE
TO FULLY IMPLEMENT- NOT ONLY
THE DIVERSION PROGRAM TO
CONTINUE TO WORK AND WE'VE
BEEN. DOING AT FORTY BILLS TO
CURE TREATMENT PROGRAM AND-
STATEWIDE ON DIFFERENT SIX
SPECIALIST- WORK ON TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE- FELONY CHARGES CHARGES
THAT PARTICULAR- BUT- WITH LOW-
RISKS. AND LOWER LEVEL FELONY
CHARGES AS AS WHAT WE WOULDBE
REFERRING TO- SO THAT CHIU
PSYCHOLOGIST SPECIFICALLY WOULD
WORK IN COORDINATION WITH THE
FRIENDS THAT SPECIALIST THAT WE
WOULD HAVE STATEWIDE THAT-
MISCAST MADE IT HAD NOTED- THEY
REGIONAL CENTERS- ONE OF THE
AREAS THAT WE HAVE REALLY
LACKS- IN OUR SYSTEM IN THIS
EFFORT. HAS BEEN A COORDINATED
EFFORT WITH OUR REGIONAL
CENTERS- AND THEN ALSO- WITH
THE COURTS TO IDENTIFY A STRONG
PLAN FOR THE INDIVIDUAL- WE ARE
REALLY PLEASED TO REPORT THAT
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY LOWERED
OUR WAIT LIST- IN THE JAILS-
THROUGH SOME OF THE INITIAL
WORK- RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A LEVIN
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE WAITING
FOR- I DECISIONS IN
TRANSFERRING TO- PARTICLE
SECURE TREATMENT PROGRAM- OR
YOU KNOW AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE DIVERSION PROGRAM
BEING ABLE TO IDENTIFY HOW TO
SUPPORT. THEIR EFFORTS TO- GO
AHEAD AND RETURNED TO THE
COMMUNITY STATE PLAYED THOSE
DECISIONS ARE MADE THROUGH THE
COURT PROCESS- BUT BECAUSE
WE'LL BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
SPECIALIST BE ABLE TO
COORDINATE AND DO THE WORK
TOGETHER THAT WE CAN- BEST HAVE
A PLAN NOT ONLY FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS- BUT THE SAFETY OF
THE COMMUNITY AS WELL. I'M SO.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. THIRTY PM. OKAY THE
THANK YOU MUCH AND IN IMPORT
FUNCTION OKAY A DEPARTMENT FIND
ANYTHING ON THIS- CRISPR.
DEPARTMENT FINDS NOTHING
FURTHER AT. COLAIO ASSEMBLY
PEDIG L. A. NOTHING- WE
REVIEWED THIS I REQUEST AND
DON'T HAVE ANY MAJOR CONCERNS
WITH THAT THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DIRECTOR PARCHMENT
MISS CASTANEDA OKAY MOVING ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE AGAINST
MARTHA SENATE BUDGET OPTIONS
AND WE'RE GONNA AGAIN ASK THE
L. A. O. A TO PREVENT PRESENT
THE FOLLOWING PROPOSALS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR SONYA PADDOCK
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND AS YOU JUST NOTED
THE SUB COMMITTEE ASKED OUR
OFFICE TO PRESENT THE PROPOSED
THESE PROPOSALS PUT FORWARD BY
THE SENATE DEMOCRATS. AND THE
SENATE DEMOCRATS ARE
CONSIDERING THE FOLLOWING
PROPOSALS TO IMPROVE SERVICES
TO THE INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
COMMUNITY- ALL THE PROVIDING A
HIGH LEVEL DESCRIPTION OF THESE
PROPOSALS AND WOULD NOTE THAT
THERE ARE MORE DETAILS IN
TODAY'S HEARING AGENDA. AS WELL
AS FROM THE HEARING AGENDA FROM
FEBRUARY TWENTY THIRD. SO THE
FIRST PROPOSAL WOULD ELIMINATE
FUNDING SUSPENSIONS FOR
SPECIFIC PROVIDER RATE
INCREASES IMPLEMENTED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET AX AND PROVIDE
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THAT
PURPOSE- IN ADDITION IT WOULD
ELIMINATE FUNDING SUSPENSIONS
FOR IN THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE AND PROVIDE ON GOING
FUNDING TO PERMANENTLY END OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE. THE
SECOND PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND OR ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO DO THE FOLLOWING.
ONE ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD ALLOW REGIONAL CENTER
DIRECTORS TO IMPROVE HEALTH AND
SAFETY WAIVERS. THE SECOND TWO
WOULD ADOPT PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO WAIVE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR IN PERSON
SERVICE COORDINATION MEETINGS
AND EARLY START SERVICES. THE
THIRD WOULD ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO ALLOW
CONSUMERS AND FAMILIES TO
UTILIZE PARTICIPANT DIRECTED
SERVICES FOR PERSONAL
ASSISTANCE INDEPENDENT LIVING
AND SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT. THE
FOURTH WOULD ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRING
REGIONAL CENTERS TO SECURE OR
FUND CRITICAL GENERIC SERVICES.
NUMBER FIVE ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
INCREASE UTILIZATION OF THE
PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM AND
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT INCENTIVES AND
NUMBER SIX BEGIN IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS AS
RECOMMENDED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN DDS FENDER RATE STUDY.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND AGAIN- WITH THE
SENATE. THE SENATE DEMS PLAN TO
BUILD BACK BELIEVE THE AND IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE- REALLY
TAKE CARE OF THOSE IN OUR
SAFETY NET THIS IS ANOTHER ONE
OF THOSE ISSUES THAT WE SPENT
QUITE A BIT OF TIME I'M TALKING
ABOUT OR- OR- IDT COMMUNITY
AND- THE TREMENDOUS IMPACT THAT
CODE HAS- HAS PRESENTED WITH TO
THEM BUT ALSO- THE HISTORIC.
STORABLE LACK OF FUNDING AND-
MMHM SOMETIMES WE DON'T ALWAYS
CARE FOR. THE THOSE WHO WHO MAY
NEED MORE CARE SO THIS ONE SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE HEARD
ABOUT ABOUT. THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES AND PAYS FOR OUR OUR OUR
OUR PROVIDERS- GOING TO GET RID
OF THOSE SUSPENSIONS HERE
PEOPLE ARE PAID OR OR- IF
REQUIRED TO WORK. ON HOLIDAYS
TAKEN AWAY PEOPLE'S HOLIDAYS ON
THE ABILITY FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE VIRTUAL MEETINGS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO KEEP
THAT OPEN- ALSO TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. CLIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WITH MORE RESOURCES
THAT THEY ARE ARE CAN SELF
DIRECT AND THEN FINALLY
PROVIDING PATHWAYS FOR. A
DISTANCE CARE GIVER COMMUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE IN EVEN
MORE SKILL TRAINING. TO CREATE
A REAL SKILL AT PATHWAY GOING
FORWARD SO PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THIS IMPORTANT CARE BUT
TO GROW AND DEVELOP- SO THAT
THEY CAN TAKE CARE OF THEIR OWN
FAMILIES. AT THE SAME TIME- SO
WE THINK THESE THINGS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT AND WE HAVE A PANEL
HERE TO ALSO TALK SOME MORE
ABOUT THIS- WE HAVE THREE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SPEAK ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF THESE- AND THAT'S
THE WAY IT SAY MORE FROM THE
HE'S A SENIOR POLICY ADVISER
FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS. WE HAVE
BURIED GIORGINI EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES SOCIAL
ASIAN AND JORDAN LINDSEY THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ARK
OF CALIFORNIA. IF YOU COULD ALL
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS
PROPOSALS. THAT THE SENATE DEMS
HAVE PUT FORTH. START WITH USE
WHITE. THANK HERO- GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS HI MY
NAME IS STILL WHITE SEAL AND I
AM HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
THE COSBY NINETEEN PANDEMIC-
PRESENTED OUR STATE NATION AND
INDEED THE WORLD WITH
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES THAT.
ONLY BEEN UNPRECEDENTED IN
NATURE AND- THE PANDEMIC HAS
ALSO LAID BARE THE NEED FOR
SYSTEM WIDE CHANGES IN OUR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM
WHILE THE NEED FOR IMPROVEMENT
HAS BEEN A TOPIC OF DISCUSSION
IN THE SUB COMMITTEE. THE
PANDEMIC FOR SOME CHANGES TO
MEET THE URGENT NEEDS OF
CONSUMERS AND FAMILIES
INCLUDING POLICY AND PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY FLEXIBILITIES MANY
OF WHICH WE BELIEVE SHOULD BE
MAINTAINED EVEN AFTER THE
PUBLIC HEALTH. EMERGENCY FOR
EXAMPLE THE INCREASE
FLEXIBILITY WITH TELESERVICES
TELEMEDIA MEANS PARTICIPANT
DIRECTED SERVICES AND RATE
ADJUSTMENTS ASSOCIATED WITH
HEALTH AND SAFETY LABOR RATE.
THESE FLEXIBILITIES HAVE
PROVIDED A CRITICAL LIFELINE TO
CONSUMERS AND FAMILIES THAT
MOST THAT MOST NEED SUPPORT AND
WE BELIEVE THESE I SHOULD
BECOME PERMANENT- WITH REGARDS
TO THE HEALTH AND SAFETY WAIVER.
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY WAIVER
APPROVAL PROCESS HAS BEEN. HAS
LONG BEEN A PROBLEM IN THE
SYSTEM WHILE AT DDS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE THE
TIMELINE TO ISSUE APPROVALS
DELAYS STILL OCCUR APPROVING
HEALTH AND SAFETY WAIVERS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL NOT ONLY HAS-
SPEAKS NOT ONLY SPEEDS UP BUT
ALSO PUTS THEM IN THE HANDS OF
THOSE WHO BEST KNOW THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. WITH REGARDS TO
VIRTUAL MEETINGS UNDER THAT
CALIFORNIA'S EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES ACT REQUIRING IN
PERSON SERVICES WHERE WAIT TO
ALLOW FOR TELESERVICES DO TO
COPE AND- THIS REALLY ENABLED
IN PRINCETON TODDLERS TO
RECEIVE SERVICES LIKE SPEECH
THERAPY. BERKELEY ONE REQUESTED
BY A PARENT GUARDIAN OR OTHER
LEGAL REPRESENTATIVE. AGAIN
WHILE THIS WAS DONE TO PREVENT
THE SPREAD OF COBIT ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS WERE INDEED FOUND BY
FAMILIES INSPECT EFFORTS
INCLUDE NOT HAVING TO
PARTICIPATE IN TRANSPORTATION
THE CHILD'S INCREASED COMFORT
BEING IN THE FAMILY HOME. AND
FOR FAMILIES WITH MULTIPLE
CHILDREN PARENTS DIDN'T HAVE TO
HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE CARE GIVERS
TO ACCESS SERVICES. ALSO IT
WOULD PARTICIPATE WITH REGARDS
TO PARTICIPANT DIRECTED
SERVICES IN RESPONSE TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND
RECOGNITION THAT TRADITIONAL
SERVICE DELIVERY HAS BEEN
DISRUPTED LEADING MANY
CONSUMERS WITHOUT ANY SERVICES
AT ALL. DDS AS MENTIONED
EARLIER AT TEMPORARILY EXPANDED
PARTICIPANT DIRECTED SERVICES
TO INCLUDE PERSONAL ASSISTANCE
INDEPENDENT LIVING SKILLS AND
SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT SERVICES.
THESE FLEXIBILITIES AFFORDED BY
THIS MODEL ARE KEY TO REDUCING
PURCHASED SOME SERVICE
DISPARITIES BECAUSE- IT MAKES
IT EASIER FOR CONSUMERS AND
FAMILIES TO FIND PROVIDERS THAT
SPEAKER PREFERRED LANGUAGE AND
PROVIDE. AND FIND PROVIDERS
DURING THE HOURS FOR WHICH
SERVICES ARE NEAT. AND FINALLY-
WITH REGARDS TO GENERIC SERVICE
SAYS THAT DESPITE REGIONAL
CENTERS RESPONSIBILITIES TO
IDENTIFY AND PURSUE ALL
POSSIBLE SOURCES OF FUNDING FOR
CONSUMERS. SERVICE COORDINATORS
HAVE OFTEN PLACED THE BURDEN ON
INDIVIDUALS WITH IDT AND THEIR
FAMILIES IS TO NAVIGATE COMPLEX
SYSTEMS OF CARE TO FULLY
EXHAUST THESE FUNDING STREAMS
THEIR GENERIC AGENCIES. AND
SOMETIMES EXHAUSTION MEANS
ATTAINING A WRITTEN NOTICE
OTHER TIMES IT MEANS GOING
PURSUING AN ADMINISTRATIVE
APPEAL AND THE END RESULT IS
OFTEN THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH ID
P. AND THEIR FAMILIES OFTEN
GIVE UP AND GO WITHOUT THE
NEEDED SERVICE BECAUSE- THEY
ARE UNABLE TO MEET THE REGIONAL
CENTER REQUIREMENTS TO PURSUE
CROSS THE SERVICES. AND THROUGH
AND GO THROUGH GENERIC AGENCIES.
ADDITIONALLY THE RESOLUTION
PROCESS FOR REGIONAL CENTERS TO
CARE SERVICES FROM GENERIC
AGENCIES IS UNDER UTILIZED. AND
UN NECESSARILY LIMITED TO
CHILDREN UNDER SIX YEARS OF AGE
WE ARE PROPOSING IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE SYSTEM AND CONTINUE TO
WORK IN COLLABORATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TOWARDS THIS GOAL.
LOWS IN WHILE THE DIRECTIVES
WERE ISSUED THESE DIRECTIVES
WERE ISSUED IN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY TO MITIGATE THE NEGATIVE
EFFECTS OF THE PANDEMIC ON THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM.
THESE FLEXIBILITIES HAVE REALLY
MADE LIFE MUCH EASIER FOR
CONSUMERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AND DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA BELIEVES FIRMLY THAT
IT WOULD JUST BE UNFAIR TO
STRIP CONSUMERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES OF THESE IMPROVED
ACCESS TO CRITICAL SERVICES AND
BENEFITS THEY RELY ON. AND WE
ASK THAT YOU WOULD MAKE
PERMANENT THESE DIRECTIVES AND
SUPPORT OTHER SYSTEM WIDE
CHANGES SUCH AS THE SUGGESTED
IMPROVEMENTS TO GENERIC.
CRITICAL GENERIC RESOURCES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IF WE COULD NOW HEAR FROM
AB BERRY JERRY. ON TO DISCUSS
THE EXPECTED IMPACT THE
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
UTILIZATION OF THE P. I. P. AND
THE CIA PROGRAMS. ON IDENTITY
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
VERY CHARGING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY ON OUR TRAILER
BILL PROPOSAL TO AMEND THE PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM IN
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT INCENTIVES- THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
HAD A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
EMPLOYMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AND WE BELIEVE
OUR PROPOSAL- WILL WILL HELP
MOVE FORWARD AND YOU KNOW PUT A
JUMP START ON STARTING TO
RECOVER SOME OF THE LOSSES THAT
WE SEEN AN EMPLOYMENT- DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND REALLY BUILD
ON SOME OF THE PROGRESS THAT WE
WERE SEEING- BEFORE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY- SO. PRIMARILY
ARE ARE CHANGE ON THE PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM HAS TWO MAIN
FUNCTIONS IT WOULD
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE- THE
AMOUNT OF EARNINGS AVAILABLE TO
INTERNS IN THE PROGRAM BY
REMOVING A STRICT EARNINGS CAP
OF TEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED.
AND INSTEAD IMPLEMENTING AN
HOUR'S CAP WHICH IS MORE IN
LINE WITH WHAT THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATION WAS
BACK IN TWENTY SIXTEEN- WHEN
THEY'RE PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
WAS WAS CHAPTER- BY MOVING IT
BACK TO IT. AS MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE IN THE STATE THE
AMOUNT OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN THE PROGRAM HAS
DECREASED PROPORTIONATELY-
BASED ON THAT STREET EARNINGS
CAP SO BASICALLY WE'VE LOST 30%
OF THE OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS
THROUGH THE PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM AS WE'VE SEEN THE
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE FROM TEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR TO THE CURRENT.
A THIRTEEN OR FOURTEEN AN HOUR-
ADDITIONALLY- WE'RE WE'RE
PROPOSING TO ALLOW FOR AN
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE TO BE
PROVIDED TO- SERVICE PROVIDERS
TO HELP FACILITATE AND MAKE
MORE MAKE A BROADER NETWORK OF
PROVIDERS ELIGIBLE AND ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE AND SUPPORT THEIR
CLIENTS IN THE PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM CURRENTLY. THEY HAVE TO
DO THAT AT A LOSS- MAN YOU'RE
DOING IT ANYWAYS BUT
NEVERTHELESS- WE'RE WE'RE
PROPOSING 15% ADMIN FEE WHICH
IS IN LINE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES FOR OTHER
SERVICES IN OUR SYSTEM- ON THE
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT IT'S AND INSTRUCTOR
FOR. IT UP OF EXISTING
INCENTIVE. REALLY IS A WAY TO
TRY TO JUMP- SOME OF THAT
EMPLOYMENT LIKE I MENTIONED
BEFORE BUT ALSO TO RECOGNIZE.
SOME OF THE UNFUNDED COSTS-
THAT GO INTO ATTAINING
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT AND FINDING GOOD
PLACEMENTS THINGS LIKE JOB
DISCOVERY- EMPLOYMENT
EXPLORATION. AND SOME OF THE
SOFT SKILLS DEVELOPMENT THAT IS
REQUIRED TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
ARE SUCCESSFUL AND COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT. SO THOSE
ARE SERVICES THAT NOW ARE NOT
FUNDED UNDER THE SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT RATE- THE SUPPORT
EMPLOYMENT RATE GOES
SPECIFICALLY TO JOB COACHING.
AND WE ALREADY KNOW BASED ON
THE RATE STUDY OF TWO YEARS AGO
THAT SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT IS
UNDERFUNDED BY OVER 36% THAT
WAS WHAT WAS FOUND IN THE RATE
STUDY AND I BELIEVE MANAGER YOU
SPOKE TO SOME OF OUR
UNDERSTANDING IN OUR SYSTEM- IN
AN EMPLOYMENT SERVICES. OUR OUR
NEW NO STRANGER TO THAT SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE- THESE TWO-
CAN JOIN PROPOSALS WILL AGAIN
JUMPSTART AND WE WILL SEE. SOME
GROWTH WE WERE SEEN PROGRESS IN
THESE PROGRAMS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC CARE LIKE I SAID. BUT
WE STILL UNDERSTAND
CONSIDERABLY ON THE TWENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION- TO THE TUNE OF
ALMOST A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PROGRAMS. AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE. THESE THESE PROPOSALS GO
INTO PLACE THAT COULD BE STILL
DONE UNDER THAT EXISTING TWENTY
NINE MILLION DOLLAR PREPARATION
WE'RE NOT EVEN ASKING FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION YOUR
TIME THIS MORNING AND. AND
HAVING ON THE AGENDA VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. THANK YOU VERY I
THINK THAT ONE THING WE CAN ALL
AGREE UPON COMMON TO THE HUMAN
EXPERIENCES DESIRE TO KNOW THAT
WE ARE VALUED. AND I THINK
HAVING THESE INTEGRATED WORK
PROGRAMS JUST PROVIDES ONE MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE IN THE DD
COMMUNITY TO FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE VALUE. AND I THINK THAT IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY BOTH AS A
GOVERNMENT AS A SOCIETY TO
PROVIDE AS MANY OPPORTUNITIES
AS WE CAN. FOR PEOPLE TO FEEL
VALUED AND INTEGRATED PART OF
OUR SOCIETY SO WE THANK YOU FOR
THIS UP THE SPINE PROPOSAL AND
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU DO. A I
KNOW A- AS- DESERVE A REALLY
IMPORTANT INTERESTING SPACE TO
BE ABLE TO WORK IN IN. IN
HELPING PEOPLE INCREASE THEIR
SKILLS AND- REJOINING GO OUT
INTO THE WORK FORCE. INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT WORK SO WE THANK YOU
FOR THAT- IF WE CAN HEAR FROM
MISTER JORDAN LINDSAY PLEASE-
AND- ON THE NEXT ISSUE. HER
AUNT AND REPOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- IT'S AN. HONOR TO
BE WITH YOU TODAY- IN THIS A
BIG. MY NAME IS JORDAN AND SAM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE R.
CAN YOU NOT POLICY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIONS I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO SPEAK ON THE CHALLENGES OF
THE WORK FORCE- IN
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
TRANSPORTATION DSPS- IS SO JUST
QUIT A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
AS A DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL DSP IS SOMEONE WHO
WORKS DIRECTLY WITH PEOPLE WHO
HAVE INTELLECTUAL OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. D.
S. P. IS AIM TO ASSIST PEOPLE
IN REALIZING THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL THEY HELP PEOPLE
BECOME INTEGRATED AND ENGAGED
IN THEIR COMMUNITY IN THE PAST
DSPS WERE TRAINED AS CARE
GIVERS BUT OVER THE PAST FEW
DECADES THE NEEDS OF THOSE
BEING SERVED HAS HAS DEFINITELY
CHANGED THE ROLES OF INDIA'S
PIAS HAS CHANGEDNOW INDIA'S
PEACE TAKE ON DIFFERENT ASPECTS
AND ROLES OTHER THAN JUST CARE
GIVING IS NO LONGER ABOUT DOING
THINGS FOR PEOPLE BUT RATHER
IT'S ABOUT SUPPORTING THE
INDIVIDUAL TO LEARN HOW TO.
REACH. THEIR POTENTIAL AND DO
THINGS FOR THEMSELVES.
THROUGHOUT THE FEEL OF
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA THE ROLE OF DSPS IS
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT WHICH IS
DIFFERENT IN CARE GIVING. AND
CARE GIVER WILL DO SOMETHING
FOR SOMEONE LIKE PICK UP
GROCERIES IN CONTRAST DSP WILL
WORK WITH SOMEONE TO ENABLE
THEM TO DO THINGS INDEPENDENTLY.
TO CHOOSE THEIR OWN GROCERIES.
IN THIS WAY DSPS TEACH PEOPLE
HOW TO DO THINGS INDEPENDENTLY
AND THE SKILLS REQUIRED FOR
QUALITY SERVICES FROM A DSP GO
FAR BEYOND. ASSISTANCE WITH
DAILY LIVING THE DSP MUST ALSO
BE A JOB COACH A COMMUNITY
INTEGRATOR. IN ADMINISTRATIVE
ASSISTANT. IN OBSERVER OF
HEALTH CARE CHANGES BEHAVIOR
SPECIALIST- JOHN F. KENNEDY
JUNIOR STATED THAT THAT QUALITY
IS DEFINED AT THE POINT OF
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE STAFF
MEMBER. IN THE INDIVIDUAL WITH
THE DISABILITY- AND SO THAT'S
WHAT I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY IS HOW DO WE INCREASE THE
QUALITY AND HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
WE ARE RESPECTING AND- I'M
GIVEN COMMITMENT TO THE DSP
WORKFORCE- I CAN HONESTLY SAY
IT WAS. THE BEST JOB I'VE EVER
HAD. THREE YEARS AS A D. S. B.
IT'S INCREDIBLE WORK SO QUICKLY
WHO ARE THE DSPS IN CALIFORNIA
WE ESTIMATE THERE ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DSPS. 82% ARE
WOMEN. 8% OR NOT WHITE. ONLY 7%
OR SINGLE PARENTS. THIS PART IS
TRAGIC 34% WORK MUST WORK
TWENTY PLUS HOURS AT A SECOND
JOB 34% US FOR TWENTY PLUS
HOURS AT A SECOND JOB 36% ON
MEDIC CAL THEMSELVES. I'M
THROUGH THE CODEPENDENT MAKE WE
HAVE SEEN THE S. P.'S BECOME
HEROES THEY'RE ALREADY HEROES
AND NOW WE ARE RECOGNIZING THAT
FOR THEIR RESPONSE DURING THE
PANDEMIC SACRIFICING SO MUCH OF
THEMSELVES TO MAKE THEIR
SAFETY- TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES. OUT THE
PANDEMIC I'M IT HAS TRULY BEEN
INSPIRING TO SEE HOW DSPS EVER
HAVE RESPONDED AND HAVE- ACTED
SO HEROICALLY DURING DEPENDENT.
BUT THERE IS A PROBLEM. FOR ALL
THAT WE EXPECTED DSPS FOR HOW
MUCH WE NEED DSPS WE DON'T. WE
DON'T RESPECT THE S. B. AND
THIS IS EVIDENCED BY A 50%
TURNOVER RATE IN OUR SYSTEM OF
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT RECOGNIZE DSPS. WE DO NOT
OFFER A CERTIFICATION WE DO NOT
OFFER PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE
TRAINING AND WE CERTAINLY DO
NOT PROVIDE. PAY FAIR WAGES FOR
THE HEROISM THEY HAVE DISPLAYED
IN FOR THEIR ONGOING SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH ID DE WE
BARELY PAY DSPS MINIMUM WAGE.
THESE LOW WAGES ARE A RESULT OF
THE LOW RATES THE STATE PAYS
PROVIDERS- LOW WAGES IS ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS BUT THE LACK OF A
CLEAR CAREER PATH IS ANOTHER.
AND BECAUSE OF THESE PROBLEMS
THE IMPACTS OF INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES CAN BE DISASTROUS. AS
A REAL LIFE EXAMPLE IT IS NOT
UNCOMMON FOR THE PAST PRESIDENT
OF OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS TO GO
THROUGH FOR. FIVE OR SIX DS
PEAS IN ONE YEAR FOR HER AND
ALSO. HOW IS THAT. IS
CALIFORNIA CONTENT WITH THAT.
THAT'S THE QUESTION WE MUST ASK
OURSELVES. INSTEAD I BELIEVE
NOW IS THE TIME TO TELL THIS
CRITICAL WORKFORCE THAT WE SEE
YOU WE RESPECT YOU AND STARTING
NOW WE'RE GOING TO ENABLE YOU
TO BETTER SUPPORT THE CLIENTS
THAT YOU ARE SO PASSIONATE
ABOUT. THE ARC IN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION ALONG
WITH OUR BUT MANY MEMBERS OF
THE LANCMAN COALITION PROPOSED
THAT WE DO SO BY THE FALL. ONE
CREATE A CERTIFICATION FOR DSPS
THAT INCLUDES BEST PRACTICES
TRAINING AND ONGOING EDUCATION.
AS MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
ARE WELL AWARE THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY PRECEDENCE IN THIS
STATE FOR CERTIFICATION FOR
EXAMPLE CERTIFIED NURSE
ASSISTANT CNA AND CERTIFIED
HOME HEALTH AIDES. ADDITIONALLY
THE DDS RATE STUDY ALSO
SUGGESTED CREATING SOMETHING
SIMILAR TO THIS A CHEER DSP
CERTIFICATION PROCESS SUCH AS A
D. S. P. ONE TWO ONE THREE
BASED ON YOUR TRAINING. THERE
ALREADY EXISTS TRAINING MODULES
THAT ARE USED NATIONALLY THERE
ARE LOCAL AD HOC CERTIFICATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED TO TRY
TO FILL THIS VOID SO THIS CAN
BE DONE IT'LL TAKE WORK I'M
SUCH AS FINALIZING THE
CURRICULUM BUT IT CAN BE DONE
AND SHOULD BE DONE AND WE
SHOULD ACT BOLDLY TO DO SO.
NUMBER TWO PROPOSAL RELATED TO
THIS IS TIED THE CERTIFICATION
TO INCREASE WAGES THIS CREATES
THE INCENTIVE FOR BETTER
QUALITY AND OUTCOMES AS WELL AS
BEGIN TO PAY MORE LIVABLE WAGE
TO OUR DS PEAS THIS IS ALREADY
BEING EXPLORED IN MANY OTHER
STATES AND ENACTED IN SOME AS
AN EXAMPLE THE STATE OF INDIANA
I'M BAY INCREASE WAGES BY THREE
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS AN HOUR
FOR DSPS WILL COMPLETE.
CERTIFIED TRAINING THESE
INCREASE WAGES CAN EASILY BE
ACHIEVED BY FOLLOWING SOME OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE DDS
RATE STUDY TO PAY FAIR RATES
AND THE THIRD AND FINAL
PROPOSAL RELATED TO THIS IS
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THE
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION FOR
THAT SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE THIS TRAINING TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES IT TAKES TIME AND
MONEY FOR INDIVIDUALS COMPLETE
THESE TRAININGS FOR EXAMPLE
ASEAN IN CALIFORNIA. IS A
HUNDRED HOURS- SO WE MUST
INCLUDE FUNDING NOT ONLY FOR
THE WAGE INCREASES FOR THE
CERTIFICATION BUT ALSO FOR THE
INITIAL TRAINING FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO DO THAT- TO
COMPLETE THOSE HUNDRED DOLLARS
OR HOWEVER MANY HOURS. YOU FOR
DSP CERTIFICATION. CREATING
THIS CREE PATH FOR. IS FOR FROM
THE ONLY PRO. WE ARE PUSHING
YEAR FOR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS
INCLUDING A SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL FOR THE
USE OF THE ONE TIME AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN FUNDS. AND REGULAR
ONGOING BUDGET PROPOSAL SUCH AS
IN THE AGENDA OF THE
ELIMINATION OF THE SUSPENSIONS.
I KNOW PROPOSALS ARE CERTAINLY
BOWL. AND WILL BUILD BACK
HOLDING- IT WILL BUILD BACK
BELIEVE IT AVAILABLE SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO GIVE
ATTENTION TO ALL THOSE
PROPOSALS AND CERTAINLY. OUR
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THE KAROQ
EFFORTS THAT THE U. S. P.'S-
CODE RESPONSE. AND ALSO OUR
COMMITMENT TO THEM AS WE BUILT
BACK IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
THE SUBJECT. THANK YOU VERY.
MISTER LINDSEY I THINK THAT. WE
HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR WE COVERED
THIS LAST COUPLE MONTHS AGO-
AND I THINK WE ALL HOPEFULLY WE
HAVE RESPONDED WITH KIND OF
HANNAH AND THESE PROPOSALS HAVE
BEEN GOOD AND WE ARE. FOR ONCE
AND FOR ALL HOPEFULLY REALLY
GOING TO ET FOLKS ON A PATH-
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT 50%
TURNOVER RATE AND YOU CAN
IMAGINE OF PEOPLE MAKING LESS
THAN MINIMUM WAGE WORKING LONG
HOURS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THEY'RE ALSO STRUGGLING WITH
HOMELESSNESS THEMSELVES AND
AFFORDABILITY AND FOOD SECURITY
AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
TRAINED TO BE ABLE TO DO YOUR
JOB. OR FEEL LIKE YOU'RE MAKING
A DIFFERENCE IN THE BURN OUT
EVEN HIGHER SO- YOU KNOW WE CAN
TALK A LOT ABOUT OUR VALUES OF
CARING FOR THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE BUT- A PROPOSAL LIKE
THIS. TAKES CARE OF THE PEOPLE
THAT WERE TRYING TO SERVE AS
WELL AS THOSE CARE GIVERS. AND
FAMILIES AND IT JUST IT JUST
HELPS THE WHOLE SYSTEM SO- WE
ARE EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO.
FINALLY HAVE SOME FUNDING TO BE
ABLE TO WORK ON SOME ISSUES
LIKE THIS. OCTOPATH THANK YOU-
JERRY WHEN NIGHT- JUST-
PROCEED- AGAIN OUR- PROPOSALS
ARE MOVING FORWARD ESPECIALLY-
WE'VE TALKED A LOT THIS YEAR
BUT WE TALK EVERY YEAR HER
ABOUT- ESPECIALLY THE FUNNY
SUSPENSIONS BEING LEFT IN PLACE
AND WHILE. THEY DON'T AFFECTED
MEDIA BUDGET OF COURSE THAT.
KEEPS OUR HEALTH EVEN SERVICES
INCLUDING AT THE MOMENT THE
SERVICES ON THE CHOPPING BLOCK-
DURING DOWNTURNS. AS WELL SO-
AND CERTAINLY TO OTHER-
MEASURES I GUESS I WOULD ALSO
JUST POINT OUT THAT- CAN
CERTAINLY PROUD THAT- HERE IN
THE SENATE TO IN OUR BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND- YOU KNOW BUDGETS
ARE CHALLENGING BECAUSE STILL
WE- THAT THEY'LL HAVE TO BE
BALANCED AND LOUIS- AND SO. BUT
WE I THINK IT'S USUALLY- YOU
KNOW WE- WE'VE WE'RE USUALLY
THE ONES TAKING THE STEPS TO
TRY TO EXPAND AND INCREASE OUR
SUPPORT AND SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
IN THE DE. COMMUNITY BEYOND
WHAT. USUALLY IS PROPOSED-
INITIALLY SO- SO I DO HOPE THAT
THERE'S SOME RECOGNITION WEEK
OF THE I THINK THERE'S ALWAYS
DESIRED IT WE COULD JUST. TRY
TO DO MORE BUT- BUT THAT
CERTAINLY- HERE IN THE SENATE
WE- ARE TO CONTINUE TO NOT JUST
SOME PLEASE. ACCEPT WHAT'S
PROPOSED BUT I CONTINUE TO PUSH
TO. INCREASE FUNDING AND CITY
IT INCREASE SUPPORT FOR- FOR
CAREGIVERS. AND DID YOU DO TO
ME THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- BUT- PARTY FINANCING YOU
ONE TO ADD ANYTHING- CHRIS
BROGAN OF THE PERMANENT
FINANCE- NOTHING FURTHER
ADVENTURE OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY THE NEXT. PROPOSAL
WERE ALSO GOING TO ASK THE L.
L. A. O. TO COVER FOR US. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- SO ANY
PARTICULAR LMAO AND THE ISSUE
BEFORE YOU- IS A PROPOSAL FROM
THE STAKEHOLDER AND THERE'S
ALSO NO AND ACCOMPANYING-
POLICY BILL- THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LIVING NETWORK
REQUEST TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR FOR A PILOT PROJECT
THAT WILL DEVELOP SERVICE
OUTCOME BASED MEASUREMENT
TRAINING QUALITY AND DATA
COLLECTION TOOLS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY SERVICES. THANK YOU
OKAY THANK GOODNESS IT WAS A
POLICY BILL ON BY MR MULLIN AB
EIGHT THREE THIRTEEN THAT WE'RE
NOW IMPLEMENTING A DEPARTMENT
FINANCE DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING ON
THIS. CHRISTOPHER O'NEILL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- NOTHING
FURTHER ADVENTURE EXCEPT THAT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS OKAY THANK YOU.
OTHER DEPENDING ON US. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY A
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING WELCOMING DIRECTOR.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WELCOME. HELLO I'M
HERE THIS MORNING TO PRESENT
BRIEFLY ON THE SPRING BC PEACE
WITH MYSELF AND MY CHIEF DEPUTY
MARK BUCKLEY- AND LOOK FORWARD
TO THE DISCUSSION AND THE
CONVERSATION AND FIRST ONE IS
AGAIN THANK THE SENATE FOR THE
BILL BACK BETTER PLANNING
INCLUDING OLDER ADULTS SO
THOUGHTFULLY. THERE BUT THE
FIRST BRING BT PAID- IT'S
EXTENDED INCREASE FUNDING OF
THE AGING DISABILITY RESOURCE
CONNECTION THIS IS IN SUPPORT
OF. A SHARED GOAL TO HAVE THAT
ONE STOP. SINGLE PUBLIC PORTAL
FOR INFORMATION ABOUT AGING
DISABILITY THAT CONNECTS YOU TO
THE EXPERT ADVICE YOU NEED AND
SUPPORTING. HOME AND COMMUNITY
LIVING AND THERE WAS AYE AYE GI
JANE REFUSAL TO HELP STRENGTHEN
THE LOCAL NETWORKS THAT WE
TRULY HAVE THAT LOCAL
EXPERTISE. IN OUR AREA AGENCIES
ON AGING AND INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTER PARTNERSHIP AND THIS IS
A PROPOSAL FOR NEXT WEEK
BACKGROUND. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE A COMMON SEE OUR COMMON
DATA SYSTEM A COMMON PHONE
SYSTEM ARE COMMON SCREENING AND
TRAINING AND REFERRALS THAT
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS. AND IS
CERTAINLY THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
DH CS TO APPROPRIATELY PULL
DOWN MEDICAID FUNDING OFFER THE.
SUPPORT INCOMING COMMUNITY
LIVING. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS TO HAVE ELABORATE
OKAY- THANK YOU. FOR A
FINANCIALLY ONCE ANYTHING ON
THIS BEFORE WE MOVE ON. ALEX
LIMITED FORMER FINANCE. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT OKAY. RIGHT
OKAY SO LET'S MOVE ON THEN TO-
ISSUE NUMBER TWO. THANK YOU
HAVE ISSUE NUMBER TWO NEGATIVE
THE HEALTH INSURANCE COUNSELING
AND ADVOCACY PROGRAM THIS IS
THE PUBLIC INFORMATION THAT WE
PROVIDE FOR MEDICARE AND OTHER
COUNSELING TO OLDER ADULTS.
INSURANCE OPTIONS COUNSELING
THIS IS NOT A REQUEST FOR
GENERAL FUND THIS IS A REQUEST
FOR AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS FUNDS IN THE ACCOUNT
SPECIAL FUNDS OF THAT FIVE
THIRTY HAS BEEN CAPPED FOR
YEARS EVEN HAS THE FUND HAS
BEEN BUILDING UP. AND WE WANT
TO MAKE AN INITIAL INVESTMENT
IN THE STAFFING AND VOLUNTEER
CAPACITY OF THE HIGH CAMP
COUNSELORS ALL ACROSS THE STATE
TO MEET INCREASING NEEDS FOR.
I'M CALLING WITH MEDICARE
OPTIONS AND MEDICARE ADVANTAGE
AGAINST CAN SUPPORT THAT HELP
ME COMMUNITY LIVING. AGAIN
THERE'S MORE TO SAY ABOUT MY
CAPS BUT I WILL STOP THERE AND
SEE IF THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR- A DETAILS WE CAN
PROVIDE. BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HIGH GIPSON OF INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM I. JUST LOVE
SEEING OF THE VOLUNTEERS AND
ALL MY COMMUNITY CENTERS. IN
THE DISTRICT AND I HAVE FRIENDS
WHO AFTER A AFTER RETIREMENT
PEOPLE BECOME HIGH CAP-
VOLUNTEERS WHICH IS A GREAT
PROGRAM- DEPARTMENT FINANCE DO
YOU HAVE ANYTHING ON THIS.
WELCOME A PERMANENT FINANCE WE
SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT'S
PROPOSAL I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT LMAO. THANK YOU
PRISCILLA SAID BALANCED OFFICE
WE REVIEWED THE PROPOSAL AND
HAVE NO CONCERNS. OKAY DR GRANT
NO OKAY WELL IF I KEPT. ALL
RIGHT IF WE CAN MOVE ON TO-
DOLLAR MASTER PLAN ON AGING.
YES ISSUE THREE THIS SPRING
BCBS THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
IMPLEMENTATION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN JANUARY
THERE WAS- IF YOU WILL A PLACE
HOLDER FOR THIS- AND NOW WITH
THE MASTER PLAN RELEASED THE
FIRST WEEK OF JANUARY WERE ABLE
TO. PROVIDE THAT I'M MORE
DETAIL ABOUT WHAT
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD LOOK LIKE
IF I COULD STOP YOU ONE MINUTE
MISBAH DIRECTOR- BECAUSE I KNOW
WE HAD THE BILL THOSE GOALS
RIGHT THAT AND SO I WAS GONNA
ASK YOU IF YOU CAME IN ONE WEEK
YOU TALK ABOUT THE- HOW WE'RE
GOING TO IMPLEMENT IT IF YOU
COULD MAYBE SPEAK TO THE GOAL
THAT IS A DRESSING. WHICH AND
AS YOU KNOW GOAL NUMBER ONE WAS
HOUSING FOR ALL AGES AND STAGES
GOAL NUMBER TWO WAS HEALTH
REIMAGINE GOAL NUMBER THREE WAS
INCLUSION AND EQUITY NOT
ISOLATION GOAL NUMBER FOUR WAS
CARE GIVING THAT WORKS IN GOAL
NUMBER FIVE WAS AFFORDING
AGING- SO. WE ADD USUALLY KNOW
THAT WE'VE BEEN SAYING FOR
YEARS THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
MORE ON AGING AND- THIS LAST
TWO YEARS WE DEVELOPED THIS
PLAN NOW WE GET TO IMPLEMENT IT
SO- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THESE
GREAT IDEAS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT IF YOU COULD MAYBE
HELP US UNDERSTAND WHICH ONE
OF THE GOALS IT FITS UNDER.
YOUR AND I APPRECIATE THAT THAT
THAT. OF THE NAMING OF THE
FIVE. GOALS AND THAT THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT THIS IS ABOUT SO.
WHAT I WOULD SAY HERE WITH THIS
IS A THIS IS ABOUT. IS ABOUT
THE CAPACITY TO DO TWO THINGS.
ONE IS TO HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE
DID WE MEET THOSE GOALS TO
REMAKE THOSE INITIATIVES ARE
THE DATA DASHBOARD INDICATORS
CHANGING SO FOR EXAMPLE. IF WE
KNOW WE'RE NOT DOING ENOUGH TO
PREVENT FALLS AND CAL IN
CALIFORNIA COMPARED TO
NATIONAL. METRICS ARE ARE FALL
INVESTMENTS FALL PREVENTION
INVESTMENTS AND HOME
MODIFICATION INVESTMENTS.
WORKING SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SET UP WITH OUR- OUR
DASHBOARD. OUR IMPACT
STAKEHOLDER COMMITTEE OUR
PROGRESS REPORTS WHICH- WE'RE
CURRENTLY SERVING ALL THE
CABINET RIGHT NOW TO FIND OUT
HOW THEY'RE DOING. ALSO A BIG
PIECE OF THE MASTER PLAN-
INFRASTRUCTURE AT CDA IS AROUND
ACCOUNTABILITY. ON MAKING SURE
IT'S NOT JUST THE PLAN ON THE
SHELF THAT WE ACTUALLY. DO AND
THAT INCLUDES THE LOCAL
PLAYBOOK WE WERE HOPING TO MOVE
FROM. A THREE COUNTIES WITH
MASTER PLANS FOR AGING TALK
FIFTY EIGHT- THAT'S OUR THAT'S
OUR NOT SO OF OUR SPONSOR
GOOGLE IN THAT AREA SO IT'S A
LOT OF IT IS THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. BUT THE OTHER
PIECE I WOULD SAY- IF THE
INITIATIVE IMPLEMENTATION.
ANOTHER WONDERFUL THING ABOUT
AGING AND I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS.
FOR WHERE YOU SIT AS WE AS A IS.
WORK SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT.
FOR ALL AGES AND STAGES
OPERATING YOU'RE ACTUALLY
TALKING ABOUT MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING THE
WONDERFUL LEADERSHIP HAPPENING
AT OUR HOUSING AGENCY. THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES-
AND PUBLIC HEALTH NURSING HOMES
THERE ARE HOUSING OPTIONS. ALL
ACROSS THE DEPARTMENTS AND SO
ONE OF THE- GOALS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF BEIJING IS TO BE
MORE OF THAT. A PERSON CENTRED
VIEW THAT CAN CONECT THE WHOLE
CONTINUUM OF CARE- AND ONE
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE OF THAT IS OUR
LAST FRIDAY. WE AND WITH
SECRETARY KELLY CONVENES THE
NEW COMMUNITY LIVING ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WAS STAKEHOLDERS THAT
HAVE. IF I GOT DISCOUNT RATE
FIVE AGENCIES SEVEN DEPARTMENTS
AND ONE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN
ATTENDANCE- TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
IT REALLY MEANS TO. TO ACHIEVE
HOLDING COMMUNITY LIVING.
SEPARATELY WE WOULD HAVE POLICY
POSITIONS- ARE AT ACTED
APARTMENT AGING CREATING THIS
NEW POLICY SHOP THAT WOULD LOOK
AT THE HOUSING. CONTINUUM THAT
WOULD LOOK AT ISOLATION AND ALL
THAT IT MEANS IN TERMS OF YES
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BUT ALSO
OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK AND
VOLUNTEER IN CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. SO I WE BELIEVE THAT
THAT POLICY SHOP IS CRITICAL TO
PROVIDING THAT PERSON CENTERED.
DOWN ALIGNMENT UP. OLDER ADULTS
AS THEY SERVE. THE MANY
DEPARTMENTS AGE. ARE AND MAYBE
IT THE COURSE OF THEIR AGE-
THAT WE WANT TO BE SURE PROVIDE
THAT PERSON CENTRED PAULA.
LEADERSHIP ACROSS THE GOALS-
OTHER PIECES IN THERE INCLUDE-
WE DON'T HAVE OUR AGING
PROGRAMS AND DATA SYSTEMS YET-
AND- THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
IT RIGHT FROM THE START. AND SO
WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING VERY
CLOSELY AT AN AGING SYSTEM FOR
AGING AND DISABILITY DATA
PROGRAMS THAT NOT ONLY WOULD
ALLOW US TO PERFORMANCE MANAGE
AND BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT DATA.
BUT CRITICALLY CONNECTED COUNTY
SOCIAL SERVICES FOR AGING
CRITICALLY CONNECT WITH HEALTH
PLANS FOR AGING- WORK FOR BOTH
THE TRIPLE A.'S IN THE IOC'S.
SO THERE IS A HUGE OPPORTUNITY.
TO USE THAT TECHNOLOGICAL
BACKBONE ALSO TO MAKE SURE
THAT- YEAH ONE STOP FOR
CONSUMERS- WITH THE PROBE BUT
BUT- NETWORKS TO WDSU. NITTY
AND HEALTH SERVICES THAT ARE
PART OF. AND WHEN IT THERE BUT
I'M HAPPY ANSWER ANY MORE
QUESTIONS AND THAT. THE YOUR
CALL. YES IT YES IT DID YES IT
DID- AND TELL ME HOW YOU LANDED
ON THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS IS
AS WERE AS AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THIS AND WE'RE BUILDING
BACK BOLDLY. AND TELL ME HOW
YOU LANDED ON ON THE FIVE IN A
THREE AND- A AND TEN IS IT JUST.
WE'RE GONNA START. YES IT'S
REALLY TIED TO THIS TO YOUR
WORK PLAN THAT WAS RELEASED THE
TWO YEAR INITIATIVES AND WHERE
THE FOCUS IS AND WHERE THE
ATTENTION IS SO HOUSING WITH A
PRIORITY AYE ISOLATION COMING
OUT OF- THAT THAT THE TERRIBLE
STATE HOME PERIOD EYES WITH
HUGE PRIORITY SO WAS REALLY
LINING UP WITH THE INITIATIVES
FOR THE NEXT- TWO YEARS THAT
HAVE BEEN PRIORITIZE WHERE WE
NEED CAPACITY- AND THEN THE I.
T. ON SOME OF THOSE POSITIONS
ARE MORE TRADITIONAL WORK WITH.
OUR COLLEAGUES IN FINANCE ON
WORKLOAD AND CAPACITY AND OUR
OUR CHIEF- OUR AGENCY
INFORMATION OFFICER AT CHS ASK
I CAN HAVE W. MORE QUICKLY CAN
PROVIDE MORE ABOUT KIND OF THE
WORKLOAD ANALYSIS THAT WENT
INTO THAT BUT IT WAS A LINE AT
THE STRATEGIC LEVEL WITH THAT.
THE PRIORITIES IDENTIFIED IN
THE MASTER PLAN. OKAY THANK
YOU- OKAY ANTARCTICA. THANK YOU
AND APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION- I GUESS IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO HAVE A LITTLE
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT EXACTLY
THE I. T. WORK- AND- WELL
CERTAINLY WE'VE HAD MANY
SUCCESSFUL IT PROJECTS HERE IN
THE STATE- USUALLY WE WANNA BE
SURE THERE'S ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT- SO I GUESS MY FIRST
QUESTION ABOUT THE I. T. WORK
IN A NOTE THAT FOR THE SPRING
FINANCERS MAINLY ABOUT
POSITIONS IS THIS ALL WORK THAT
CAN BE DONE IN HOUSE OR IS ARE
THESE STAFF TO BE BROUGHT ON
AND THAT WE'RE TO EXPECT A- A
REQUEST FOR A CONTRACT AND YOU
STILL BATES DOES IT WORK ALL IN
HOUSE IT WORK THAT'S GOING TO
BE DONE ORDERS ARE PLANS BY THE
PART OF AGING TO THEN. AND
DINNER EFFORT TO IMPLEMENT
THIS- STATEWIDE CLIENT
RELATIONSHIP MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
THAT CENTER- IS IT IS THAT
GOING TO BE TAKEN OUT A HOUSE
OR IS THAT DALY. IS THE SECOND
HE TOLD AN IN HOUSE PROJECT. I
CENTER GRAND IS MORE WAITING TO
HELP DEPARTMENT. AND I'M HAPPY
TO. QUESTIONS THE ANSWER IS
IT'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE BIT
OF BOTH. AND PARSLEY AND HOUSE
AND PARTIALLY CONTRACTED OUT.
SO WITH OUR CLIENT RELATIONSHIP
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT WE'RE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY. TO HELP US ASKING
ABOUT PROJECT I'M ADEQUATELY
AND TO PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
SUPPORTS RESOURCES. IN ADDITION
A SEAT YOU WOULD ALSO BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
AGENCY. INFORMATION OFFICER- AS
WELL AS THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION. I'VE BEEN JUST
TREMENDOUS VERY VALUABLE
SUPPORT- AND REALLY HAVE HELPED
US GUIDE US THROUGH THE POWER
PROCESS. WE HAVE GONE THROUGH
THE FIRST STAGE OF THE POWER
PROCESS WHICH IS THE S. ONE BA
OR- A STATE ON BUSINESS
ANALYSIS THAT WE DO HAVE THAT
COMPLETED- IN THIS PROJECT WE
ARE GOING TO. BUT ALL OF OUR
LOCAL AREA AGENCIES ON AGING AS
WELL AS OUR AGING AND
DISABILITY RESOURCE AND ACTION.
OUR PROGRAMS ON TO ONE PLATFORM
AND THAT'S THE GOAL OF THE
PROJECT. AND WHAT WE INTEND TO
DO IS- IN OUR REQUEST WE DO
REQUEST ADDITIONAL. DEVELOPER
RESOURCES AS WELL AS AN
ENTERPRISE AND- TECHNOLOGY
ARCHITECT. HELP US REALLY
PROPERLY BUILD THIS OUT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE ALL THE
TECHNICAL SPECIFICATIONS
CRACKED. OR WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE TRIPLE A
DIRECTORS AS WELL AS THE EIGHTY
ARE SEEING WEEDS. RIGHT SURE
THAT IT MEETS THE PROPER
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS- AND
ULTIMATELY THIS WILL NOT BE A
SOLUTION- WE WILL BE
CONTRACTING WITH AN EXISTING
APP PROVIDER. OF AGING AND
DISABILITY I'M SYSTEMS YOU ARE.
IT SERVICE THIS ENTERPRISE
PLATFORM. WE ALSO HAVE A
REQUEST FOR TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO HIRE. AND
ENTERPRISE TECHNOLOGY AND
CONSULTANTS AND SEVENTY TWO
SMALLER WITH AND IMPLEMENTING
ENTERPRISE. SOLUTIONS THAT
MAKES- THAT WE'RE DOING IT
RIGHT AND THAT WE HAVE- ALL THE
WORKING PROPER. AND THAT HAVE
THIS IS BUILT ON AT. IS MICHAEL
AND. YES IT IS INCLUDED AS PART
OF THE SPRING FINANCER WE'RE
REQUESTING THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. OKAY ALL
RIGHT- OKAY SO I GUESS WHAT I
WOULD JUST SAY THIS AGAIN- YOU
ALWAYS HAVE THE SPRING FINANCE
LETTER WE ACTUALLY THAT LEVEL
DETAIL AT LEAST LET'S NOT AND A
DESCRIPTION. OF WHAT HUMANITY
UP HERE THERE IT IS- IT JUST
SAYS TO CONTACT AUTHORITY TO
IMPLEMENT- SO- SO I GUESS WHAT
I WOULD JUST SAY IS THAT- I
HOPE THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO MAYBE A MORE-
SPECIFIC OVERSIGHT- HEARING ARE
NOW WITH THE SAY SEPARATE
HEARING BUT OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
A DISCUSSION ABOUT EXACTLY
WHAT. THE SCOPE OF THIS IT
EFFORTS GOING TO BE- MAYBE ALSO
HAVE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
JOINED PART OF AGING- TO JUST
SO WE HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF
WHAT THE I. T. PROJECT IS
PERHAPS SO HIS BILL- MORE TIME
THAT WE HAVE DROPS TODAY TO GO
INTO THIS IN MORE IN DEPTH-
ALSO. I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
GIVEN WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING
RIGHT NOW WHICH I THINK IS THIS
THE RIGHT TIME FOR YOU ARE YOU
READY TO TELL US YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO DO SO I KNOW
YOU'RE DOING SOMETHING YOU'RE
DOING STAGE ONE EXPLORATION
IT'S ADDRESS. AND ALSO A NOSE
MENTIONED BY THE DIRECTOR- BUT
ALSO HOW THIS HOW YOUR PLATFORM
MAYOR YOU KNOW WILL WILL
INTERFACE WITH THEIR INTEGRATOR
AND CONNECT WITH. THE VERY
LARGE ACTUALLY I. T. PROJECT
THAT'S GOING ON OVER AT- IN
SOCIAL SERVICES- CAL SAWS
ETCETERA SO I KNOW THAT THAT'S
GOING ON AS WELL- AND ACTIVE I
THINK IT DOESN'T GET. CLOSED
DOWN ON QUOTE UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR BUT OBVIOUSLY. MY
COME SERVICES YOU WANT TO BE-
INTERFACE THERE SO I SO
PROBABLY THIS IS NOT THE TIME
TO DO IT RIGHT NOW BUT I'M
HOPING THAT- WHETHER IT'S- JOB
YOU KNOW. BUT AFTER THE BUDGET
OR SOMETHING WE PERHAPS SHOULD
HAVE A AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE.
THIS DISCUSSION AND MAYBE IT'S
PART OF A LARGER HEARING ON THE
MASTER PLAN IMPLEMENTATION BUT.
WE SHOULD HAVE A PARTICULAR I
THINK- DISCUSSION ABOUT MORE
SPECIFICS YOUR AYE T. PRO. THAT
SAW. IT'S SCOPE. HOW IT. AND
THEN ALSO YOUR- TO MOVE FOR TO
TAKE RE. ARE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR WE WILL THAT ARE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I THINK IT SOUNDS
LIKE A GREAT IDEA TO HAVE A
SOMETHING ON A MASTER PLAN ON
AGING JUST IN SPECIFIC BECAUSE
WE ALL HAVE. A LOT OF INTEREST
IN THIS AS WE AS WE MOVE CLOSER
TO IT ALL THE TIME A DEPARTMENT
OF A FINANCIAL AREAS YOU DO YOU
HAVE ANYTHING ON THIS. OUR
PLANS- WHICH IS. THE PART.
DOUBLES AND ARE READY FOR
PROBLEMS. CALIO REVIEWED THE
PROPOSED NOW AND AT THIS OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY LET'S
ON TO- THEN ISSUE NUMBER FOR
FROM THE B. C. ALL OF LONG TERM
CARE. OR REPRESENTATIVE. MR YES
AND I'M TO HAVE THAT YES YOU
CAN TO BE A- THIS IS OKAY. YEAH
MARC YOU DIRECTOR FOR
DEPARTMENT A HAPPY TOO PURSE ON
THIS. I'M SORRY IN THE CORE
CARE CAN'T VERSUS MATH- THE
COURT. MADE CLEAR IF TO
EXISTING LAW THAT THERE SHOULD
BE A PATIENT REPRESENT. I
PROVIDED AT INTO. TEAM HELD FOR
INCOME. PATIENTS WHO ARE A AND
REPRESENTED. SO CURRENTLY IT'S
A REQUIREMENT THAT ALL
FACILITIES ATTEMPT TO FIND
REPRESENTATION FOR AND
REPRESENTED PATIENTS- WHAT THIS
PROPOSAL SEEKS TO DO IS
ESTABLISH NEW OFFICE TO.
PROVIDE THAT PROVIDE THAT LEVEL
OF REPRESENTATION TO
UNREPRESENTED PATIENTS- SO AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT AGING
WE PROPOSE TO. HIRE SIX STAFF
TO SET UP AND ESTABLISH THE
PROGRAM AS WELL AS ENTER INTO
CONTRACTS WITH LOCAL PROVIDERS
TO- YOU DELIVER THE SERVICES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL- SO THAT'S YOU
KNOW THAT'S WHAT THE PROPOSAL
AND DOES- WE DID NOW TO
QUESTION- IN THE AGENDA. ABOUT
THE FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM AND
WHY WE'RE PROPOSING THAT THIS
BE PAID THROUGH THE- LICENSING
FEES. THAT CITY CAGES **** AS
OPPOSED TO GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION. AND WE DID LOOK
AT THAT ISSUE AND- YOU KNOW WE
DO THINK SINCE THIS IS EXISTING
LAW THAT WAS CLARIFIED THAT
THIS IS AN EXISTING OPERATING
COSTS OF THE FACILITIES. AND
THEREFORE SHOULD BE BORNE BY
THE FACILITIES- WE DON'T SEE A
CONFLICT. BECAUSE SINCE THE
SINCE THE FEES WILL BE
COLLECTED BY CDPH AND PROVIDED
A CDA CDA WILL HAVE- OVERSIGHT
AND AUTHORITY OVER THE PROGRAM.
THE FACILITIES WON'T BE EN THE-
PROCESS OF SELECTING THE LOCAL
PATIENT ROCKS THAT WE ALL
DRIVEN BY CTA AND CDA WILL BE
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT OVER THE
PROGRAM. YEAH WE DON'T SEE.
THAT- YOU KNOW FINDING THE
GRAMS YOUR LICENSING FEE WOULD
RESULT IN ANY STORE OF CON WE
DO THAT IS- AFFABLE. AND SET UP
AN THE WAY THAT THE FOR IS JUST.
THAT WOULD AVOID CON. YEAH
THANK YOU BYE. DEPARTMENT FOR.
OF ALAMEDA BIRDS IT WAS FOR THE
PROPOSAL ALSO. YOUNG THAT THE
WRITING H. REPRESENT BUT THE.
MADE I RESPONSIBILITY ABLE.
THIS PROGRAM IS. HOLDING OF
ABOARD THE HIGHER COSTS I COULD
GO. A FOREVER UNDER. NATION AND
THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT THE
FUNDED THROUGH THE LAST NAMES.
DAHLIA HI WE REVIEWED AND HAVE
NO CAN. OKAY HERTZBERG PM.
THANK YOU ESTIMATE THAT I DO
HAVE GOOD ABOUT USE THE LIGHTS
IN FEE AND- ACTUALLY BACK TO
THE QUEEN L. A. SAID CONCERN SO-
THE ADVOCATES ARE THIS IS YOU
YOU THINK THAT- AND
MINISTRATION CLAIMS THAT
THERE'S NO OF FIRE BUT SO IT
WAS LOOKED AT THIS ISSUE AND
THAT SOUGHT LEGAL COUNSEL.
BELIEVE THIS IS NOW GOING. TO
THIS IS JACKET ALLEGE THAT OP-
WHAT WE SAW LEGAL. IT'S OUR NEW.
THAT I'M USING THE FEE IN A IS
V. SO IT IS A VERY SIMILAR
APPROACH THAT WE FOR REYES.
INVOLVED PRACTICES. FOR SKILLED
NURSING- SO IN MAINTAINING THAT
A FIRE WALL- AT IT MAKES THAT-
YOU'RE YOU'RE A TO AVOID THE-
OF INTEREST THROUGH THIS MODEL
HOWEVER IF. WE'RE NOT ATTORNEYS
SO IF THE LARGEST WE LIKE US TO
SPECIFICALLY OUT THAT LEGAL CAN.
WE'RE HAPPY TO DO THAT AS- OKAY
PERHAPS- WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
L. A. L. THROUGH OUR LEAD
COUNSEL- I MEAN I THINK THIS
ISSUE IS BEEN REYES. AND I IT'S
CLARIFY THIS- BEFORE WE MOVE
FOR IF POSSIBLE THANK. OKAY.
SHOULD WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD OUR WAIT FOR THE
CHAIRED RETURN. OKAY THAT'S
FINE. I THINK WE JUST HAVE L.
A. OSTER READING PROPOSALS BUT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT NOW LET'S MOVE
ON THEN TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
AND I BELIEVE LA IS GOING TO BE
READING THE SENATE- BUDGET-
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
I'M ISSUE NUMBER FIVE I'LL BE
READING THE SENATE BUDGET
OPTIONS RELATED TO AGING ISSUES
SPECIFICALLY THE SENATE IS
CONSIDERING THE FOLLOWING
BUDGET PROPOSALS ONE OF OUR
MANY THE FUNDING SUSPENSION AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING SENIOR
METRIC PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION ONGOING FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS THIS REFLECTS A
PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES HEARD BY THE
SUBCOMMITTEES- HEARD AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S. MARCH SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HEARING.
SECOND IS ELIMINATE THE FUNDING
SUSPENSION FOR EIGHTY OR SEIZE
AND PROVIDE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THE STATEWIDE EASIER C. NETWORK
THIS REFLECTS A PROPOSAL PUT
FORWARD BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES
HEARD AT THE SUB COMMITTEES
MARCH SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
HEARING. THIRD PROVIDING
ONGOING FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
DIGNITY AT HOME FALL PREVENTION
PROGRAM AND MAKE IT PERMANENT
THIS REFLECTS A PROPOSAL PUT
FORWARD BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES-
HEARD AT THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
MARCH SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
HEARING. FOURTH PROVIDING ONE
TIME FUNDING TO BRIDGE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TABLETS AND OTHER
DEVICES TO OLDER CALIFORNIANS.
THIS WILL BUILD ON CBA'S
CURRENT PARTNERSHIPS WITH AT&T
AND GOOGLE TO PROVIDE TABLETS
AND SMART SPEAKERS THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE LOWER
INCOME AND LIVE ALONE. BETTER
THAN LAST IS PROVIDE BASELINE
ONGOING. FOR AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING THIS REFLECTS A PROPOSAL
PUT FORWARD BY THE CALIFORNIA.
ASSOCIATION OF AGENCIES HEARD
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEES MARCH
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
HEARING AID FOR ADDITIONAL
DETAILS ON ANY OF THESE
PROPOSALS- YOU MAY WORK- PLEASE
REFER TO THE MARCH SECOND
HEARING AGENDA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH M. AND
WE'LL HAVE MORE FROM THAT SEEM
HEARING. LATER ON LET'S- LET'S
GO WE HAVE WITH US TODAY-
VICTORIA JOB DIRECTOR VENTURA
COUNTY AREA. AGENCY ON AGING TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT. THE
IMPACT THESE PROPOSALS WOULD
HAVE. I'M GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE THANK-YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY I WORK FOR THE COUNTY OF
VENTURA AND DIRECTOR OF THE
AREA AGENCY ON AGING AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING. ADDITIONALLY MY TRIPLE A
IS ONE OF SIX DESIGNATED AGING
AND DISABILITY RESOURCE CENTERS
AND THE STATE LOCALLY WE
PARTNER WITH OUR INDEPENDENT
LIVING RESOURCE CENTER TO
PROVIDE THIS NO WRONG DOOR
ACCESS TO SERVICES WHICH IS
REALLY A BIG CRITICAL TRENDS
TEND TO MAKE. THE NEEDS OF
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE VAST AND
GROWING AND WILL CONTINUE TO
EXIST HOST ENDEMIC HOW WE
SUPPORT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
REALLY IS A MEASURE OF OUR
HUMANITY SINCE THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC AREA AGENCIES ON AGING
STATEWIDE HAVE RISEN TO THE
OCCASION AND I'VE MET THE
INCREDIBLE DEMAND FOR SERVICE.
NEEDED TO KEEP OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE. DISABILITY SAFE AT HOME.
THIS MEANT THE DELIVERY MEALS
WELL I TO PEOPLE HOMES. WELL
ALMOST BECAUSE AND PORCHES.
THANK PRO. AND CLASS ON.
DISTRIBUTING AND TRAINING OLDER
ADULTS ON HOW TO USE DIGITAL
DEVICES. ANSWERING CALLS AND
CONNECTING PEOPLE TO SERVICES.
PROVIDING RIGHTS TO COPE WITH
TESTING IN VACCINE SITE.
PROVIDING IN ABOUT THE VACCINE
ARRANGING FOR AND HOME
VACCINATIONS AND OTHER SERVICES
TO SUPPORT OLDER ADULTS AT
HOME. THE SERVICE IS BEHIND
THESE PROPOSALS TODAY HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN ALLOWING
AGENCIES LIKE MINE TO QUICKLY
RESPOND TO AN UNPRECEDENTED
UNPRECEDENTED DEMAND. AND WILL
ALLOW US ALLOW US TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO A
VULNERABLE POPULATION. CODE
EXPOSED THE FRAGILITY OF THIS
POPULATION AND THE GREAT NEED
THIS WILL NOT END WHEN KOBE
DOES TRIPLE A.'S NEED THE
BASELINE FUNDING INCREASED
OPERATE. WITHIN INCREASED
POPULATION THIS WILL HELP
SUPPORT OUR INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT THE GROWTH OF THE
POPULATION. BUT ALSO OUR
CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING LOCALLY.
ADDITIONALLY WITH SEVENTEEN
MILLION MEALS SERVED FREE
PANDEMIC AND A PROJECTED THIRTY
TWO MILLION MEALS TO BE SERVED
THIS YEAR EXISTING FUNDING DOES
NOT SUPPORT THIS INCREASED
LEVEL OF MEALS. WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL ONGOING INCREASED
SUPPORT WHEN THE CURRENT
DOLLARS RUN OUT AND THE GREAT
LAKES DELIVERED PROGRAM AND WE
ARE LOOKING AT A MASSIVE CLUB
FOR OLDER ADULTS. ELIMINATING
THE SUNSET DATE AND PROVIDING
THIRTY FIVE MILLION ON AN ON
GOING FUNDS WILL HELP US. MEET
THIS ENORMOUS NEED. THE FUNDING
FOR THE EXIST ANIMAL EIGHT OUR
SEAS HAS BEEN CRITICAL. AND
ALLOW TRIP A.'S LIKE MINDED
WERE TO THIS NEED. FOR THE
STATE EARLIER. WE WERE ABLE TO
HIRE THE STAFF AND HAVE THEM IN
PLACE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE THE
CALLS- THEY CONNECT PEOPLE TO
THE RESOURCES WITHOUT THESE
FUNDS WE TRULY WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO RESPOND AS QUICKLY
AND EFFECTIVELY. I'M GOING
FUNDING IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
ACCESS AND EQUITY FOR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY LIVE. THE DIGNITY
AND HOME FALL PREVENTION
PROGRAM FUNDING REALLY IS IT'S
BEEN GREAT AND HAS ENABLED US
TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
COMPREHENSIVE FALL PREVENTION
SERVICES THAT HAVE PREVENTED
FALLS AND ENABLE MORE OLDER
ADULTS TO BE ABLE TO AGE IN
PLACE AT HOME. FINALLY BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDE AND DISTRIBUTE
DIGITAL DEVICES DURING THE
PANDEMIC HASMADE OUR CONSUMERS
MORE CONNECTED AND HAS LESSEN
THE ISOLATION AND LONELINESS
FOR SOME. AS MORE OF OUR
CLASSES AND EVENTS THE GROUP
ONLINE HAVING THESE DEVICES TO
LAND REALLY HAS ALLOWED US TO
ADDRESS EQUITY ISSUES- AND ALSO
TO TARGET. THOSE MOST IN NEED.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT ON THE
PARAMETERS OF HOW THESE
ADDITIONAL DEVICES WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH L. A-
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING ON THIS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OKAY
YET THE. VERY VERY VERY NEEDED
NEEDED THINGS AND AGAIN IT IS
IT IS A RELIEF TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE SOME ROOM IN THE BUDGET TO
BE ABLE TO HELP WITH SOME OF
THESE THINGS AND ALSO HOPEFULLY
AND GET RID OF THESE FUNDING
SUSPENSIONS THAT WE KEEP USING
ARTIFICIALLY- THAT HURT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE AND WE THINK
EVERYBODY WHO WORKS IN THE
SPACE FOR ALL THE WORK AND
ISSUE AROUND FOOD SECURITY I
THINK IS GOING TO BE IT THAT'S
NOT THE FIRST TIME. WE'VE HEARD
THIS ISSUE COME UP WE'RE GOING
TO BE SUPPORTING FOOD BANKS IN
A BIG WAY BUT ALSO THIS
DIRECTLY GOING INTO THE- THE
TRIPLE H. IS REALLY IMPORTANT-
THE GREAT PLATE WAS A GREAT
PROGRAM BUT WE ALL KNOW WHAT'S
GOING TO END AND IT'S- AND
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN USING IT A LOT
SO WE NEED TO HAVE SOMETHING SO
PEOPLE JUST DON'T GO HUNGRY
AFTER DEPEND YOU HAVE ANYTHING
ON THE ON YES IT IS AGAIN
APPRECIATE THAT- JUST HAVE TO
REITERATE WELL WE'RE LEARNING
FUNDING SUSPENSIONS- AGAIN MORE.
PROGRAMS HERE- CLEAN THE SENIOR
TRICIA PROGRAM AND THE- FUNNIES
FOR THE ADR SEES AS WELL AS OF
COURSE THE OTHER THINGS WE ARE
ALSO INCLUDING AN A BASELINE
FUNDING FOR DAIRY AGENCIES
AGING SO AGAIN TRYING TO LOOK
NOT JUST AT THE IMMEDIATE
FUTURE WHICH IS WHICH WE DO DO
BUDGET YEARS AT THE TIME BUT
ALSO LOOKING HE DID A WE DON'T
AGAIN PUT- OUR SOCIAL SERVICE
FOR INCLUDING A PROGRAMS FOR
AGING ON A CHOPPING BLOCK TO
POTENTIAL CHOPPING BLOCK IS A
AND DURING ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS.
OBVIOUSLY WE DIDN'T AND DOES
ACTUATION AS WE AS A
LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE TO MAKE
HARD DECISIONS BUT AT LEAST
WE'RE NOT AUTO- WE'RE NOT
AUTOMATICALLY TWENTY ON A
CHARGE OF CHOPPING BLOCK AGAIN-
HUMAN SERVICES. INCLUDING AGING
PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY THE- CAN. THE
ITEMS THAT WERE A GOOD TO COVER
TO- WE THINK. FOR YOUR PRISON.
AND THE WORK THAT YOU PUT INTO
TO PREPARE FOR THIS COMMITTEE.
AND WE WILL NOW GO TO- OUR
FIRST FIRST WILL GO L. ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM. ONE TWELVE.
NO THERE ARE NOT OKAY SO
MODERATOR ARE YOU THERE AND ARE
WE READY FOR THE PHONE LINES.
YES WE ARE AS A REMINDER TO PUT
YOURSELF INTO CULINARY PRESS
STAR THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. BROWN'S START
WITH LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE.
BY NUMBER TWENTY NINE YOUR MIND
IS. SORRY ONE MOMENT PLEASE
HAVING A TECHNICAL ISSUE GO
AHEAD LINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN I'M MODERATE- CAN
YOU TELL ME HOW MANY CALLS ARE
ON THE LINE. I CURRENTLY HAVE
FOUR THANK YOU VERY FIRST THREE
PARDON ME OKAY. THE NUMBER
THREE OKAY OF THE FIRST CALLER
GO AHEAD. GREAT AT GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR SENATOR PANTS
JENNIFER SNYDER I'M HAPPY
COVERAGE YOU TO HELP. AND WE
JUST WANTED EXPRESS SUPPORT- AT
PETITIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NAY. AGE NUMBER. WHICH IS
ALLISON IS NOT THE LONG TERM
CARE PATIENTS A- FOR IN. AND ON
RECORD PEACE AND HOME- IT'S ONE
IF THEY WERE TO WITH THE- OF
THE FOR- WITH THAT DRAFTING
CAN'T IS CHECK COURT- AND WHILE
SUPPORT OF THEM. AND RESTAURANT.
WE HAVE TO KEEP THAT TO WITH
THE- AND- ADULT THE END ON. THE
FIRST IS THAT WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT THIS OF THE PRO WILL NOT
HAPPEN TIME NATIONAL COMPLY.
WITH THE COURT TRYING PRIMARY
MORE IS AFFECTED JULY OF THIS
YEAR- SO WE'VE THE DEPARTMENT
ELAINE THE CORPORATE FOR ONE
YEAR. UNTIL THE CAN BE IF AND
INTO CAN BE TRAIN AND THEY BILL
LAW FOR PATIENTS AND HOMES. I'M
IN ADDITION WE SELL STOCK THAT
THE OF THIS OFFICE NOT BE FOR
BY THE FACILITY LICENSE FEES
RATHER. YOUR GENERAL FUND ALL.
FOR THE QUARTER OF THE CLEAR
THAT THE SAUDIS NOT GOING FUN
AT THE STATE RECORDS AT. BAND
AND WE TRULY BELIEVE THE THIS
IS A AND I'M OPPORTUNITY FOR
THIS. AND TAKE ON HOLY THE
RESPONSIBILITY AT THE CORE
PATIENTS CO THAT ARE IN LINE
CARE IN AND THE NURSING. A DAY
TO. FROM THE NURSING. MAYBE THE
HOT TO BACK TO THE NURSING HOME.
AND SO YOU KNOW WE BELIEVE THAT
THE TO SEE- AND THE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS REALLY BY THE ON AND
STARTED THE STATE LEVEL. EXCUSE
ME. THAT ONE WENT AWAY LINE
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. MORNING KELLY
BURKE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES A CALIFORNIA THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES REQUEST
FOR THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
TO PARK. UNDERFUNDED LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCY STOPPING A
TRUCK. WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S WORK TO
RESTORE THE FUNDING AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR- LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WELL NOW
WITH A LINE NUMBER FOURTEEN
LINE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH HELLO THIS IS- HARRIS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND I WANTED TO JUST COMMENT ON
A COUPLE OF THESE PROPOSALS-
REGARDING DDS- WE CAN THAT IT
IS. THAT RATING ARE CONNECT TO
OUR- WE'VE BEEN FOR ABOUT FOUR
NUMBER OF YEARS NOW- BUT ALSO
TO BE TO FOCUS REMOVING.
BARRIERS THAT SERVICE CALL
SPEND ON- IN ORDER TO OF TIME
ON MY. ANY AND UNDERUSED. OR ON.
HOOPS WE ON A- TAKEN FAMILY AND
SERVE COORDINATORS HELPED. WERE
CLOSER CAN OCCURRING- HERE- OF
THE FIRST PIECES THAT YOU'RE
SEEING IN. WHAT THE INTERNSHIP
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE PROVIDERS.
ACTING THE ORDER BURKE AND. IN
THIRD AS FAR AS THE YEAR HE ON
BOTH THE- THE BALL- COMMITTEE.
FOCUS ON HOW AND SAFETY OF THE-
WITH THE. OF THE GUARDS. THAT.
THE QUALITY OF LIFE OUTCOMES
THAT SHE IS LIVING AND WORKING
IN THE COMMUNITY MOSTLY SAID.
SURVEY AT THE END OF COURSE AS-
WELL THAN SIX MONTHS- SO WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT YOU ARE NOT
OF WAGES- GOOD BETTER TRAINING.
ON THAT HAVE BEEN NOT THE- IN
THERE DO TO BE HONEST CURRICULA.
HE ON ALL BE BETTER PREPARED
FOR THE WORK THAT WANT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TAX COLOR. ONE OTHER
NUMBER EIGHTEEN LINE A YEAR OLD
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
THIS IS TONY THERMOSTAT THE
JOURNEY WORKED. BUDGET NURSING
HOME REFORM I WANT TO COMMENT
ON THE AGING PROPOSED ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR. THEY ARE OF ISSUE
REPRESENTS AND- WHITE CASTLE.
EXIDE THAT THERE'S PROPOSAL IS
FOR YES THEY ARE OF THE OF THE
ALL THE FUTURE PRESENT THE MUCH
NEEDED- BUT WE ALSO SHARE THE
BIG OF. HAVING A COME TO LIFE
CAN BE I WANNA- JUST. THE IDEA
THAT THIS IS A PUBLIC SERVICE.
THEY JUST HAVE TO BE PRO IN
THIS ONE. STARTING NURSERY HOME
SPEAK. REALLY JUST BECAUSE
YEARS AGO OR SO THE- NURSING
HOME INDUSTRY PERSON. PAUL ON
THE STUFF WHERE. BOTHER
SETTINGS LIKE AT THE DIDN'T
COST WERE WORKERS. SHOW UP. DID
NOT PURSUE IT THOUGH IT'S
REALLY NEAT THE STATE FUNCTION
HERE PROVIDE. ASSISTANCE WITH
FISHING HEALTHCARE DECISIONS
BUT RESIDENTS OF NOT SO MUCH A
NURSE HOME. WHEN WE SAY THAT'S
ANOTHER WERE THEY NEED TO SET
THAT THE PUBLIC ARE YOU OFFICE
THIS IS REALLY SO OF THE-
GARDEN. FLIGHT SERVICE- AND IT
REALLY BE A FUNCTION OF THE
STATE GOVERNMENT. AND PROPERLY
PLACED IN THE DEPARTMENT OF A
BUT IT SHOULD BE THROUGH THE
PHYSICAL NURSING. SERVICES THAT
THE SPRING TO KEEP PEACE
INCREASES FUNDING FOR LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES I REALLY
APPRECIATE. THE RESTORATION OF
THE SPAWNING N THE
CONTINUATION OF THAT NEW
METHODOLOGY THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED. AND THEN FOR THE-
DEPARTMENT AGING OUT CONTINUE
TO APPRECIATE THE DIRECTOR IS.
LEADERSHIP INVITATION THE
MASTER PLANNER PARTNERSHIP WITH
BACK COUNTY. AND NOW WE SUPPORT.
DIFFERENCE KEEP MOVING FOR-
REALLY WHEN I THINK THE SENATE
BUT THEY INCLUSION. OF SEVERAL
BUDGET PROPOSALS TO ISSUE
FURTHER PROGRESS ON AND
SPECIFICALLY WANT TO SHARE A
FEW FACTS SUPPORT. OFFERING
FUNDING FOR THE SENIOR PROGRAM.
THAT'S FUNNY BURKE OF THE MEDIA
ARE. AND INCREASE THE BASE
FUNDING CHIP H. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. EXCELLENT AYE NUMBERS
FIVE THIRTY YEAR ONE OPEN. OKAY
AFTERNOON THAT I'M SURE- MARKET.
REPRESENT THE LOS ANGELES BOARD
PEOPLE. IN THE- OF THE- SPRING
THESE. ACCORDING CHAU SUPPORT
IN. I JUST WANTED TO ADD- A
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS
BY TO PAY- WHO. LEAD AT TO
WHERE WE'RE AT TODAY ON- A
ADDRESSING THE- FOR THE
COUNTY'S AND ALSO- THAT THE FOR
EVERY DAY WE TO- DOLLAR IS A-
MATCH. SO IT DOES BRING REVENUE
AND REDUCE. IS DURING WHEN- OF
OUR- FAMILY THE MAINLY MOTHER
FIRST TO ENDS MEET AND SO-
APPRECIATE THE AND LISTENING TO
THE LIKES THAT ALEX. ARE
EFFICIENCY WHILE- THE OPERA. TO
PROVIDE IT- WITH OUR NEW. CHILD
SUPPORT DIRECTOR TERRY HARDY'S
THAT YOU GET TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT WHAT L. A. COUNTY HAS
DONE TO TAKE THE INITIATIVE. TO
ADDRESS PROGRAM MUSICIAN BE SO
APPRECIATE YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THIS IN THE ON THE
BUDGET HEARING AND LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING- THIS DEFENDANT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ORDER LINE
NUMBER EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU. MOTOR
FAMILY MEMBER MY OVER HAD- THIS.
AND I'M CARE IN HOME. AN ADULT
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- BEEN PART OF MY
EXTENDED FAMILY- AND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY YOU'RE
COMING ACTION NETWORK YOU
CAN'T. JUST WANT TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORTER THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS YEAR. JUST ONE
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE SENATE DEMOCRATS BUT YOUR
PRIORITIES IDENTIFIED IN THE
BILL BACK BOLDLY- ESPECIALLY
THOSE DEALING WITH HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. AND
SPECIFICALLY THE- PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE 7% REDUCTION
TITUS SAYS AMONG ALL THE OTHER
PROPOSAL. AGAIN THAT DOCUMENT I
THINK IT'S A GOOD BLUEPRINT FOR
WHERE WE NEED TO GO. AND TOWARD
THAT OF ALL FROM STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT. IN APPLIED- BY
MEDIA ADVOCATES. INCLUDING
THOSE BY. EXTRA LINE NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS MONEY TO HAPPEN RIGHT
THANK YOU. THAT PLEASE SERVING
EIGHT HUNDRED OF MIDDLE TO THE
EXORCIST GO HE'S A AND ON WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING
NETWORK I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
OUR FOR THE SERVICE OUT SHE TO
PROPEL LEVEL JUST SERVICES.
CREAMPIE PROJECT. ANSWER THE-
THAT THAT SENATE DISCONNECT
MANY WHICH THEY CALL HAVE AFTER
THE. WHAT IS THE PAINFUL IT WE
CAN BUILD SERVICES ARE SIX. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO WILL CREATE
AND CONSISTENT DELIVERY
OUTCOMES. AND RESTRICTED BY
DATA. AND MEASURING PEOPLE USED
ABOUT THE JUST SERVICES THEIR
CO POINTS OF LIGHT. DO YOU
THINK THAT SHOWS WHAT WHAT
SWEATSHIRT. MODEL WHAT PERSON
AT. THE PERSON UNDERSERVED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR
PLEASE. SIX COLORADO LINE
NUMBER THIRTY NINE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
DRAGOMAN MEMBERS- ON CANADA CAL
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
FUNGAL SACRAMENTO CALIF
PRESIDENT OF NOVEMBER
CALIFORNIA. AT ANOTHER CRITICAL
NEED IN OUR COMMUNITY A FAMILY
INCREASE. THE CREDIT AND THE
CAN DEMOCRATIC PARTY COULD
CHANGE A LOT OF OUR PRACTICES
AND HOW WE PROVIDE YOU KNOW.
BOTH OF THESE FACTORS CONCRETE
I CONNECTICUT WEEK IN NOVEMBER
SECOND I HAVE. ABOUT A WEEK
OVER TWENTY HUNDRED SENIOR AT
THAT THE PART OF THE PANDEMIC
OF THE VOLATILE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WITH THEIR THE MIDDLE
CLASS ALSO CONNECTION WE
PROVIDE THEM ALL THAT IS
KEEPING FROM HUNGER AND
ISOLATION. FOR THE FIRST YEAR
THE PANDEMIC NOT CALIFORNIA
SERVING MORE THAN SEVENTEEN
MILLION MILK CALIFORNIA NEARLY
75% INCREASE FROM THE PRIOR
YEAR. THIRTEEN ABOUT MEALS ON
WHEELS PROGRAM BUT THEY HAVE
INCREASING NUMBERS OF. I'M MORE
THAN 1100% INTERNALIZED HERE WE
CONSERVING INDICATE THEIR
CLIENT BASE HAS INCREASED BY
NEARLY SEVENTY PERCENT. IN
ADDITION TO INCREASING AND
OPERATE YOUR VEHICLE BUT IT HAS
REQUIRED IT TO MAKE SEVERAL
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN HOW WE
PROVIDE. YOU WE CAN'T DO
CONGREGATE MEALS AT THE- BUT WE
HAVE TO HOME TO. THANK YOU
PICKED MEALS- WHICH- MORE STAFF.
YOU ARE THE HEAD CONFLICT THINK
WE WORK WITH YOU ABOUT HERE YOU
TO COMPARE ABOUT THE- OUT WE
ARE HAPPY IT IS. MANAGING A
REMOTE WORKFORCE YOU HAVE TO
GETTING CLOSE WITH IT THINK
BRING PICK UP CLIENT. I WE HAVE
HAD NOT BEEN HOME- THE MOW
SUPPORT WITHIN THE PROPOSED
THIRTY FIVE. MILLION GENERAL
FUND ADMIN PATIENT. PERSON BUT
THE TO WORKING WITH THE- AND
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE OTHER
MAINTAIN IN THE FINAL BUDGET.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS COLOR PLEASE. YES AND
THERE ARE SIX LEFT IN Q.
BENNINGER AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS TO NEED A STRONG GRIN AND
I'M A VOLUNTEER FOR A RP
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF OUR THREE POINT THREE
MILLION MEMBERS AND ALL OLDER
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING ON THE
AGING ISSUES. WE APPRECIATE THE
SENATE THE BILL BACK BOLDLY
PLANS THERE IS MUCH TO
CELEBRATE IN THE PLAN AND WE
SUPPORT- THE END OF THE PHONY
BUDGET SUSPENSIONS THAT ALL TOO
OFTEN IMPACT PROGRAMS SERVING
OLDER CALIFORNIANS WE SUPPORT
THE AGING PACKAGE THAT INCLUDES
SEVERAL A. R. P. PRIORITIES.
SUCH AS THE PERMANENT
ELIMINATION OF THE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES 7% HOURS
CUT AND WE WOULD HOWEVER LIKE
TO POINT OUT IF YOU MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES AND URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THESE PROPOSALS AS YOU
FINALIZE BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS.
IT WAS VERY ENCOURAGING TO HEAR
YOU SPEAK- VERY POSITIVELY
ABOUT THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
HOWEVER- IT WAS NOT INCLUDED IN
THE BILL BACK PROBABLY PLAN AND
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING IS A
ONCE IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY.
FOR CALIFORNIA TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS OF THE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
AGES AND ABILITIES SO WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT IT WAS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE SENATE-
BUDGET PLAN AND WE ASK THAT THE
PLAN BE ELEVATED AS A PRIORITY
BY THE SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
NOTABLY BUT NOT EXCLUSIVELY WE
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF IMPLEMENTING
THESE INITIAL MEASURES FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET PROPOSAL. FIRST
ESTABLISHED A POSITION OF THE
SCENE ADVISER ON A- TO. AND NOW
HIGH IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
TO ADVANCE CROSS CABINET
INITIATIVES AND PARTNERSHIPS.
ALLOCATE FIVE MILLION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING. ALLOCATE
TWELVE POINT FIVE MILLION FOR
BOTH THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
IN THE FIRST HALF OF TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. TO EXPAND THE
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CENTERS. AND WE ARE JUST SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
CURRENT REQUEST AND THEN TO
ENHANCE ITS REQUEST. USING A R.
P. A. FUNDS. AND FINALLY WE
REQUEST THAT OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE BEEN THREATENED WITH
ELIMINATION OR SUSPEND AND JUST
LAST YEAR. INCLUDING THE
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES.
TO MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM AND THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS THE
INCLUDED IN THIS EFFORT TO
FULLY ELIMINATE THE PRACTICE OF
SUSPENSIONS. THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. OKAY LINE NUMBER FORTY
TWO FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATOR PAYER AND UNDERSERVED
RURAL SCHOOLS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE AGING PROPOSAL THAT HAD
BEEN PRESENTED TODAY WE- ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR- INITIATIVE
THAT BEEN PROVIDED BY THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING AND- BOLD
IMPLEMENTATION STEPS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT BEIJING HAS- DEFINED
IN ORDER TO- FORWARD WITH.
CRITICAL PERSON CENTERED
SERVICES AND TO ESTABLISH THE
CONNECTIVITY THAT WE KNOW IS SO
IMPORTANT DURING THE TIMES OF
ISOLATION. OF THE COMMISSION
ALSO FULLY SUPPORTS THE
PROPOSAL. PUT FORWARD BY THE-
AREA AGENCY ON AGING%
ASSOCIATION- THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL MEAL IT'S
NOT GOING TO GO AWAY- AT THE
PANDEMIC AND WE WILL STILL BE.
THE NUMBERS HAVE INCREASED
ENACT INCREASED DEPENDENCY ON
THE HOME DELIVERED MEALS- NEW
MODELS FOR DELIVERING SERVICES
ARE CRITICAL RIGHT NOW. SO
AGAIN AT OUR SKI- INCLUDING
THE- I'M SORRY THE- PAUL
PREVENTION PROGRAM THESE ARE
ALL REALLY IMPORTANT
INITIATIVES THAT WE HOPE THAT
WILL MOVE FORWARD TO YOUR
COMMITTEE AND COME OUT ON THE
OTHER SIDE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
COLOR PLEASE. WHAT OTHER LINE
NUMBER FORTY ONE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME'S MARK LANSLEY
BACKING UP DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING
NETWORK AND CO CHAIR OF THE
PATH FORWARD COLLABORATIVE. YOU
FEEL IN THE STATEWIDE
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION WITH
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND TEN AGENCY
PROVIDER MEMBERS AND THE PATH
FORWARD COLLABORATIVE A
COALITION OF FORWARD THINKING
THOUGHT LEADERS FROM THE IDB
SERVE AT THE TIME. YOU SEE A
LOT OF PROBLEMS BONTA THIS
CRITICALLY NECESSARY ONE TIME
TEN MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
REQUEST INCLUDED AN ISSUE THREE
OF TODAY'S AGENDA. THE BUDGET
REQUEST BUILDING INNOVATIVE
DATA DRIVEN PILOT PROJECT
DESIGNED TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES FAR MORE
EFFICIENTLY USING STATE
RESOURCES. IT BOLDLY ADDRESSES
THE RACIAL DISPARITIES
GEOGRAPHIC INEQUITIES AND
SERVICE INCLUDING EXCERPTS IN
INCONSISTENCIES AND FUNDING
DEFICIENCIES THAT CHALLENGE THE
IDB SERVICE BUT THEM. YES SIR
WITHOUT COMPILE IT PROJECT
BUILDS CLEARING CONSISTENT
PERSON CENTERED ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICE DIRECTIONS TO ADDRESS
THE DIVERSE NEEDS OF PEOPLE
WITH I. D. D. BETTER IDENTIFIED
SERVICE OUTCOMES THAT LEAD TO
INDIVIDUAL ACCESS TO CHOSEN WAY
OF LIFE. IF YOU ON ALL POLL
BOLDLY SUPPORT AMONG A
LIMITATION OF THE FRONT THAT
LANGUAGE BUT A COUPLE MENTAL
RATE INCREASES. IT'S
DESTABILIZING THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THE BUDGET REQUEST
THANK YOU. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WELL A LINE
NUMBER FORTY FOUR THREE YEAR IS
OPEN. YES MADAM CHAIRED CAL
TWITTER. SOCIAL OF AGE ON. I
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAKS. TO THE
BUDGET OPTION OPTION THAT ARE.
IN HE SHOULD FIVE. WHETHER
NUTRITION OUR ADRC FOR
PREVENTION OUR BASELINE THESE
ARE ALL PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO POSITIONING THE
STATE. AGING NETWORK TO BE ABLE
TO RESPOND TO THE NEEDS AND
GROWTH OF THE AGING POPULATION.
AND SO WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LOOKS COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND MATT I'M SURE WE DO HAVE
THREE LEFT IN Q. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER FORTY SIX FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE FORTY
SIX YOU MAY BE ON SELF MUTE CAN
YOU CHECK YOUR PHONE. I DON A
FINAL CAN HEAR ME WE CAN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
I AM SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THEIR YARDENI'S- REQUEST TO
INCREASE THE C. I. EASE ON
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT- BENCHMARK. DOUBLE
THOSE AND TO MAKE CHANGES TO
THE- LEARN TO PROGRAM THE KEPT-
AS MENTIONED THIS IS NOT ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING THE
FUNDING HAS BEEN USED A LOT
UNDER UTILIZED EVERY YEAR ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. WE HAVEN'T
COME CLOSE TO USING IT-
CALIFORNIA IS AN APPOINTMENT
BIRTH DATE- WE VALUE- ACCORDING
TO THE PEOPLE OF DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES YOU WORK IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THE YET THE FUNDING
TO DO THIS ADEQUATELY HAS NEVER
BEEN THERE- AND THE TAXPAYER TO
ME IT HAS ALWAYS. NEVER HAD
MAKES SENSE THAT WE HAVEN'T
REALLY SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT
BURKE PROGRAM BECAUSE WE'RE
HELPING PEOPLE GO FROM BEING
DEPENDENT ON BACK. TAXES BEING
BY RECIPIENT IS BECOMING
TAXPAYERS THEMSELVES NOT ONLY
DO PEOPLE EARN PAYCHECKS BUT
THEY BECOME INTEGRATED PART OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES THEY BECOME
GOOD EMPLOYEES OR COWORKERS-
CHANGES THAT YOU MAKE YOURSELF
WITH THAT MENTAL HEALTH CARE SO
MANY POSITIVES ABOUT HELPING
PEOPLE FIND A JOB. THE PANDEMIC
ARE OUR FOLKS ARE OFTEN- LAST
HIGHER IN THE BIRTH BY WE HAVE
ABOUT SEVEN PEOPLE OF THE
PEOPLE WE LOSE THEIR JOB AND
BEGIN THE KIND. SLOWLY GETTING
THEIR JOB. THIS MAKES TOTAL THE
MONEY THERE PLEASE THE COURT-
THAT THE- AS WELL AS THE- ONLY
OF THE- THANKS IN MY- AT KNOW I
AS THAT AS MANY AT IN OUR WORK
FORCE ARE. HEROES THEY WERE IN
THE DURING MAKE IT A NOT SO
THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
COLOR PLAY. WE'LL NUMBER FORTY
SO FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
JERRY PULL- PRISON CEO PAP-
PROVIDER. ON THE CENTRAL COAST
AND AN A. AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. YOU BRIEF
COMMENT WHICH JUST SAY YEAH A
PER- A FEW THE SERVICE. THE
SUSPEND DATES MAKE IT X.
DIFFICULT TO PLAY TO SUPPORT S.
P. IS TO PROVIDE WAYS INCREASE.
AND SOME VERY MUCH. THE TO. THE
TO SPEND DATE FOR BOTH INCREASE
IN THE UNIT HOLIDAY SCHEDULE
SHE AND THEN SECONDLY WHY SAYS
SUPPORT- ON PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM COMPETITIVE IN A- AND-
PLAN MINIMUS. A HUGE OUTCRY
ABSOLUTE THE FOLK THAT WE- EACH
OUR BRINGS DIGNITY BRINGS.
BRINGS INTEGRATION. I'M NEXT TO
THE H. C. B. S. SETTINGS FOR
ALL AND THE FUNDING RIGHT NOW
IT'S UNDER UTILIZED AND NOT
REALLY WHAT THE INTENT OF
SPECIALLY WITH THE PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM WHICH WAS
INTENDED TO BEACH AFTER YEARS
FOR IT TO WORK AND IT'S BEEN
DEVALUED BY. MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES SO VERY MUCH SUPPORT
THOSE TWO PROPOSALS AND
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
COLOR PLEASE. THANK WILL GO TO
LINE UP FIFTY FOR ONE YEAR LINE
IS OPEN. LANNISTER BRAT I AM A
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT NH GREAT
CLASSICAL PRESIDENT BUSH ZERO
WOMAN CALIFORNIA. I AM AUTISTIC
AND THERE'S A PLACE IN THE
COMMENTS OTHER PREPARE. THREE
DOCTOR USING. I'M GONNA TO PUT
THE CAR ISSUES. ALL I CAN ALL I
THE STATEMENT SUPPORT BUT MANY
FUNDING MEASURE. INSPECTIONS
FOR TO PROVIDE WHO FOR PROVIDE
RATE INCREASE. AND IMPROVING
EMPLOYMENT UP. FOR PEOPLE WITH
MY CAN. I URGE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
THIS IN. I THINK CHANGES MY
COMMUTE WEBER COMMITTEE. PLEASE
TO GET A THANK YOU THINK YOU
VERY MUCH VERY WELL DONE NEXT
CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU OUR
FINAL WARNING IS A NUMBERS TWO.
BY FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS APRIL
STEWART AND I ONLY A TWENTY
FOUR HOUR HOME CARE. WE ARE A
VENDOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM AND
THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ACROSS
THE STATE. I AM CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ELIMINATING THE
SUSPENSION DATE ON THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING INTO THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICE AFFECT THEM. IT'S
FUNDING IS NECESSARY FOR US TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO SUPPORT AND
ACCESS TO THE COMMUNITY FOR
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF IMPROVING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM FOR
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MODERATOR AS ANY OTHER.
CALLERS JOINED AT THE LINE. WE
DO HAVE TO MORE THAN A KID UP
WHICH LIKE MANY GO TO THOSE
RIGHT MADAM. SURE THANK YOU
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR BECAUSE I NEED TO
BE ASKING WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
WE THANK THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING FOR THEIR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP ON IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING. WE
ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR ISSUE FIVE IN THE
PDA PORTION OF THE AGENDA.
COUNTY WOMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENTS WORK CLOSELY
LOCALLY WITH AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING AND THE BUDGET OPTIONS
OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA OR
IMPORTANT SUPPORT THAT OUR
CONSUMERS RELY UPON. WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THESE
ISSUES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FINAL CALLER. THANK YOU WILL
GET A LINE NUMBER FORTY FOUR
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY
WESTLING AND I'M CALLING FROM
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCY IS CALLING TO
SPEAK ON THE ITEMS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES BUDGET- THE FIRST OFF
WE SUPPORT THE BCP THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
FOR THE FORENSIC POPULATION BUT
I DO WANT TO FLAG THAT. THIS
WOULD NOT PROVIDE ENOUGH
POSITIONS FOR REGIONAL CENTERS-
TO EACH HAVE ONE FORENSICS
SPECIALIST SO WE WANT TO.
REVISIT THAT ISSUE. WE
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
SENATE DEMOCRATS PROPOSAL AS IT
WOULD BE HAND IN HAND.
STABILITY AND FUNDING SENT. IT
WOULD ENHANCE STABILITY- AND
WOULD BEGIN SURE THAT. THEY
WOULD BE THE ELIMINATION OF
SUNSET FOR WHAT ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY ONGOING COSTS-
THROUGHOUT THE LAST YEAR WE'VE
SEEN THAT SERVICE FLEXIBILITY
WORK. SO IT SHOULD BE CONTINUE
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO BE SUPPORTED
IN THE WAY THAT WORKS BEST FOR
THEM. ADDITIONALLY WE WANT TO
KNOW THAT THE APPROVAL OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY WAIVERS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL HAS BEEN A
POWERFUL TOOL DURING THIS TIME.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO EXPLORING
FURTHER HOW TO- CONTINUE THIS
ONCE THE PANDEMIC COMES TO A
CLOSE. OUR COULD SUPPORT. IN
THE EFFORTS TO JUMPSTART
EMPLOYMENT AND AGREES WITH
SENATOR EGGMAN BUT IT IS A
PROVEN PATHWAY TO HELP PEOPLE
TO BE VALUED MEMBERS OF THEIR
COMMUNITY AND ANYTHING WE CAN
DO IN. THAT REGARD IS- NOTHING
BUT BENEFIT TO PEOPLE. WE AGREE
WITH THE IMPORTANCE OF
IMPROVING DSP TRAINING TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES AND
PROFESSIONALIZATION. AND KNOW
THAT IT DOES NEED TO BE TIED TO
HIGHER WAGES. TO INCREASE
RETENTION AND TO GIVE DIGNITY
AND RESPECT TO THESE CRITICAL
POSITIONS IN THE COMMUNITY. AND
FINALLY WE AGREE THAT WE NEED
TO AS A SYSTEM AS WITH
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE RATE STUDY A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THAT OUR.
SYSTEM WENT THROUGH THAT WE
NEED TO BETTER UNDERSTAND AND-
THE- OF OUR SERVICES SAYS. AND
THAT WE HAVE TO BUILD GREAT BUT
SUPPORT THOSE QUALITY OUTCOMES
AND MOVE US CLOSER. TO A SYSTEM
THAT IS REFLECTIVE OF- ENSURING
THAT PEOPLE'S INDIVIDUAL
OUTCOMES ARE. AND THEIR DESIRES
ARE MET- SO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY WHO
WHO WAS CALLED IN- AND IF YOU
DID NOT GET A CHANCE TO CALL
AND IF YOU STILL WANT TO SPEAK
PLEASE CONTACT- THE SENATE.
BUDGET ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES OR THE SENATE BUDGET
STUFF. ON TO BE ABLE TO EXPRESS
YOUR- YOUR THOUGHTS- I THINK
ALL THE STAFF. AND NEED THE
ADVOCATES WHOHAVE BEEN-
HELPING US HERE TODAY. AND WITH
THAT WE WILL ADJOURN THE
MEETING.